this course is an excellent introduction
to apis for beginners this is an updated
version of what is already one of the
most popular API courses on the internet
Craig Dennis is back as the instructor
and in my opinion he is one of the best
developer Educators out there hello I'm
Craig and I'm a developer in this course
we are going to be exploring a term that
you've probably heard quite a bit that
term is API or application programming
interface in addition to being able to
recite what it stands for when you
complete this course you'll be able to
discuss what an API does you'll
understand why they exist and you'll be
able to list the many benefits that they
provide you'll even get some hands-on
experience using a few popular web apis
which will give you a taste of what all
this excitement is about we'll be
starting from the very beginning so
there really isn't too much I'm going to
be expecting you to know before starting
this course I would like to request that
you have a touch of experience with
coding and a wee bit of knowledge about
the web if you've written any program at
all even the typical first program you
know the one where you write the words
hello world if you've done that in any
programming language you'll pretty much
be ready for this course
it will be helpful if you have a basic
understanding of how the web works with
web servers and browsers but don't sweat
it we'll touch on that too now if you
haven't met these requirements please
check the notes attached to this video
for where to get started with some
beginning web and programming Concepts
that reminds me you should take some
time to get used to your learning
environment the notes that I just
discussed are attached to this video and
I'll also drop more information into
that section to keep you updated on what
might have changed from my right now
to your right now and I'll do my best to
remind you to look in there when there's
something I think you just have to see
but you really should get in the habit
of checking that area out there will be
tons of Juicy information there
you might be getting a real bad case of
deja vu right now this is a refresh of a
course from 2019 which these days seems
like about 30 years ago or something if
you saw that version welcome back
technology is constantly evolving and
just updating the notes wasn't cutting
it so this is version two thanks for all
the feedback by the way a lot of yours
and your fellow learner suggestions are
implemented in this new updated version
all that to say we got you
these videos have captions so if you
feel like you might benefit from having
those on please use them this space is
all yours if you want me to speak slower
please use the speed controllers to slow
me down and if I'm taking a long time
speed me up I make a pretty good
chipmunk and last but certainly not
least take advantage of the fact that
you are in a video based course if you
need me to repeat myself use the video
controls to rewind me if you feel like
you need to take a break to let
something sink in by all means please
pause me I'll be right here waiting for
you I know that I've gotten into some
pretty bad viewing habits with all the
streaming media now while binging might
be a great way to consume an entire
season of your favorite show
it's not the best way to learn something
new it's education isn't meant to be
binged and because of this I'll probably
remind you quite a bit to take breaks
and encourage you to let what you just
learned
marinate all right let's get to it API
those three little letters generate
quite the buzz don't they first I'd like
to take some time up front here and
clearly break down what is meant by
application programming interface by
understanding its purpose and a touch of
its history I think you'll start to see
its importance and begin to understand
why this term keeps popping up in your
life after we get a good grasp on the
what and the why of apis we'll go and
learn how to explore two existing ones
we'll get familiar with several handy
tools that you can use to interact with
web-based apis
we'll use those tools to hit an external
web API to send actual text messages and
we'll get some interesting data back
from a streaming music service API once
we get some practice using the apis
we'll use them in a web application that
you'll actually publish the application
that we're going to be building is going
to receive user-submitted photos via a
text message and then we'll use an API
to display a collection of all these
photos and you get to come up with the
prompt send me the latest photo on your
phone dog pics please what's for dinner
whatever you want I can't wait to see
what you build and what your family and
friends submit to it we're going to be
strictly using apis in this course we
won't be writing our own while you most
likely are going to end up learning some
best practices in API design we won't be
covering that specifically there there
are many great courses available that
show The Creation thought process and
I've linked to some of my faves and the
notes attached to this video
in my opinion the best way to start
learning about any acronym is to focus
on each individual letter for API I
think we should start on that last
character the I interface let's talk a
bit about the interfaces that you've
seen already
interfaces are all around us for
instance this radio here it has a
familiar interface the interface allows
me to do things like change the volume
change the station I can turn it off and
on I literally have no idea how anything
inside this thing works but still the
interface allows me to control the way
that it works through the options that
are exposed and that's pretty great
isn't it the magic that is happening is
completely abstracted away from me I'm
still in control of what has been
determined that I a user can handle
interfaces usually evolve over time like
an alarm clock radio for example it has
my familiar volume and station controls
and it also adds some new features like
changing the time and setting the alarm
I still have no idea how this works
implementation wise but the interface is
something that I can understand
usually
and as technology evolves and new
options come into existence they make
their way into the new versions of the
interface still abstracting away things
for us but enabling us to be in control
of the new features sometimes these
physical interfaces get so recognizable
they even make it into guise hey did you
hear that there it is again gooey g-u-i
graphical user interface this is my
streaming music app on my phone there's
my familiar play button in the user
interface or UI and I know what the play
button does when I press it but I have
no idea how it does it I'm okay with
that level of abstraction what would I
do in public transit without music like
talk to people hi how's it going
now the developer who wrote this
streaming music application of course
understands how the play button Works
she coded the button so that when it
gets clicked the music starts playing
here's the thing though our developer is
also working with quite a few interfaces
that are abstracting away some of the
details for for instance she wrote code
that happens when the button is clicked
she probably did that using an event
handler on the button like on click
what she didn't have to do however was
write the code that makes the button
interact and change with the Press she
didn't have to write the code that makes
that familiar clicking noise it was
already there for her buttons are in
fact an interface they provide the
developer the means of controlling its
interactions while abstracting away how
that actually works implementation wise
this button is part of the API or
application programming interface and
it's available from the application
framework that was used to create the
app because most apps need buttons this
interface has been created and provided
to our developer or application
programmer to use by implementing the
button interface our developer was able
to make her code run when the button was
clicked it's worth noting that the code
probably also uses a media player API
that is provided with the operating
system of the device like Android or iOS
this media player API abstracts away
needing to understand details of how to
send audio data to hardware
the developer knows they just want to
call the play Method on the media player
API
I suppose too the song isn't stored on
the device it's being streamed over the
network so a web-based API call has been
made over the internet to get that data
it's actually apis all the way down to
the ones and zeros providing
abstractions at many levels so let's
take a look at what all of these
interfaces have in common they all
Define ways for us to interact or
communicate with an object whether that
object be physical or software and as a
user of the interface we don't need to
understand the implementation we don't
need to know how it works we just need
to know what we've been allowed to
change or see interfaces abstract away
the implementation now while the UI or
user interface is made for the user of
the application the API is made for the
application programmer to use and extend
in their applications
with the eye covered in our API let's
take a deeper look at the rest of the
API acronym
an API is a contract of sorts it defines
how it is expected to be used and it
defines what you can expect to receive
by using it think of it as a set of
tools designed for software developers
like yourself to use an API is created
to help make your life easier by giving
you access to data and by providing you
with an abstraction of the
implementation you know not needing to
know how it's doing whatever it's doing
they save you from needing to create
everything yourself like when designed
well they make nearly impossible things
happen with just a few lines of code now
you're probably starting to see why it's
important to get familiar with them
right I want to do a quick word of
warning here about some naming issues
that you'll probably run into these days
the term API is almost always used as a
way to explain web-based apis in fact
it's probably safe to assume that when
you hear API in the wild it's most
likely that people are talking about a
web-based API we'll explore those here
in a few
however if we focus on all types of apis
instead of just the web-based subset
we'll get a better look into why
web-based apis are so popular so hang
tight we're getting there apis are
everywhere in your software Journey just
about everywhere you look your
programming language whichever one that
might be provides many apis let's take a
look at one that is common in all of
them they all provide some way of
working with strings you know like a
series of characters want to make your
textile uppercase just call the API
method and of voila you could probably
create the uppercase string all by
yourself by doing some sort of low level
bit math on each character
but you don't need to because your
programming language has abstracted away
that for you and provided a handy string
API
it exists because this is a common
enough problem that developers run into
because these programming language
specifications are just interfaces
different operating systems can supply
their own implementation so that the
code works properly in their environment
I think an easy way of picturing this is
to think about how different operating
systems like Windows or Mac OS maintain
their files they're totally different
yet your programming language provides a
single API for working with the file
system you can write one script and it
works both in mac and windows it's the
implementation that takes care of all
the details for you pretty cool right
definitely something to be thankful for
it makes our life so much easier not
having to worry about what operating
system is being used and the importance
of an API tool language cannot be
understated there have been some
fascinating legal cases where it's been
questioned if the language API itself
again not the implementation can be
copyrighted check out the notes for more
on that along similar lines there are
different web browsers you know like
Google Chrome Microsoft Edge Safari
Firefox Brave now you might not have
pondered this before but isn't it
amazing that you can write code for the
web and it will work in any of them this
works because there's a set of web apis
that web browsers almost Implement in
order to make that magic happen for you
we're standing on the shoulders of
giants folks and we really should thank
those giants more often there are
authors and maintainers of libraries
that package up code to solve common
problems so that you don't need to do it
yourself
for instance do you know how to
programmatically make a photo black and
white me neither but I can download and
import an image package into my
application and suddenly I can I just
call a method in boom
I wish real life skills work this way
I'd import dancing so it could be more
fun at weddings
Frameworks provide an API that allow you
to extend what has been provided to make
it your own like for example most web
Frameworks provide you with the ability
to add a new route to your web
application it allows you to write out
Dynamic data to a template that you
specified and you do all of this with
just a handful of lines of code you
don't need to understand how it's doing
things but you do need to know how to
write an implementation to what the
framework is expecting in this case
you're using the API the contract to
write a valid implementation that meets
the requirements now all these apis that
we just talked about they're local to
our code base they exist within our code
we use them to avoid recreating the
wheel that is to say they assist us in
accomplishing tasks that we need to
perform by abstracting away a ton of the
work for us the stuff that we developers
shouldn't be worrying about we should be
focusing on the business problem at hand
and that means a big part of your job is
figuring out how to Leverage The these
apis to your advantage now I think this
is an excellent time for you to take a
break I just gave you a lot to think
about and I'd like you to take some time
and breathe
why don't you jot down some apis that
you've used today even if you weren't
coding I know that you've seen some in
action if you're having a hard time
thinking of some
I'll give you a hint you're watching a
video right now inside of a web browser
when we return we'll explore the concept
of remote apis ones that aren't
executing locally in our code base and
why that is such a powerful concept
foreign
[Music]
it took me a while to find this remote
control it was in the couch it's always
on the couch anyways this remote has an
interface on it right there's a power
button and when I press the channel
button it changes the channel when I
press the volume button it sends the
request to my radio and the volume
changes as if I turn the volume up using
the interface on the device itself and
we know why that's important I want to
remotely control my device I don't want
to get up from my chair there are of
course more less lazy reasons as to why
we'd want to remotely control objects
this cute little robot for instance has
a remote API you can send commands to it
and it responds and it even sends back
sensor information these traffic signs
can change based on an API call
this drone here is remotely controlled
by an app on my phone see
and it's not just physical objects that
benefit from remote apis oftentimes we
don't have space on our local machines
for all the data that's available like
for example have you ever used one of
those apps that helps you figure out
what song is playing you send up a
snippet of a song that you heard playing
at a grocery store using your microphone
and it sends back exactly what song it
is it's usually Phil Collins it turns
out that both grocery stores and yours
truly Love Phil Collins
you don't have room for all the songs in
the world on your phone and with this
remote API you don't need to have all of
them it does all the searching and
processing and it's surprisingly quick
how can it possibly do that
I don't know but I love the interface
it's so fast oh that's another benefit
of remote apis computational power
because an API removes the limitations
of your local device you can gain access
to seemingly infinite amounts of power a
good example of this is the AR app of
Google Translate
you can use the camera on your phone and
it neared real time it's able to
translate directly to your screen like
instantaneously it's using a ton of
processing power to make that magic
happen and that processing is happening
elsewhere in La nube
it took quite a bit of experimentation
and some evolution of ideas but over
time we finally turn this remote API
dream into a reality now I'm going to
drop some history into the teacher's
notes but I just want you to know that
the struggle to achieve this concept of
remote apis was very real now most of
the problem was that there wasn't a
standard that everyone loved things were
pretty clunky for a while as these ideas
were sussed out but then it happened a
new architectural style appeared that
was clear and allowed us developers to
interact with specific resources over
the web and it quite literally changed
everything this style rapidly emerged as
a winner and just about everyone began
offering and consuming external apis
over the internet
now what I'm talking about here is rest
or representational state transfer it
was the approach that we needed and
honestly it's the abstraction that we
developers deserve like we talked about
already the popularity of rest spread so
rapidly that it nearly completely
overtook the term API it's like how we
use the word Xerox to mean photocopy
even though Xerox is just a brand of
photocopier Xerox does other stuff too
I think that's how pervasive rest is
rest is for sure not the end-all be-all
of remote apis there are definitely some
limitations which we'll discuss here in
a bit Technology's ever evolving and of
course there's movements that are still
advancing the concept of the best remote
apis some terms you might even have
heard like graphql more on this in the
teacher's notes now for the rest of this
course we are going to do a deep dive
into apis that are written using the
rest style when apis embrace the style
and constraints of rest they are said to
be restful
cute right if you feel like you need a
little rest go ahead and pause me before
we do a deeper dive into what it means
to be restful sorry that was a bad and
obvious joke that as a developer you
kind of have to make it you don't really
have an option
because rest it's on top of web
Technologies like a really nice hat we
should probably do a whirlwind refresher
of how the web works
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
works there are a smattering of terms
that I'd like to reload into your
working memory before we talk more about
how rest uses them so let's use the web
I've got my computer here and on it is
an internet browser the browser is a web
client and I'm going to use it to
connect to a server I'm going to do this
by putting a location in the address bar
a universal resource locator or URL to
be exact
you might also hear this referred to by
its superset term URI Universal resource
identifier
now our URL here has a scheme portion
and this one happens to be HTTP HTTP
stands for hypertext transfer protocol
let's break that down a bit let's grab
that last part protocol
a protocol is also often likened to a
contract it's a little lower level than
an API but it's similar in concept you
can think of it as defining the
expectations of how to communicate like
an example that I think really sticks
with me is if you've ever been to a
rally and someone does one of those
chants where they're like when I say Foo
you say bar Foo bar one of those here
let's do one when I say HTT you say p
HTT HTT oh I just realized I might have
made you yell P out loud hope you're in
a coffee shop awkward
anyways we you and I just set up a real
quick protocol I told you how to respond
to my specific request and you would
have been breaking our agreed upon
protocol if you yelled anything else
but P so the browser creates an HTTP
request for you along with the URI it
also specifies a particular HTTP verb in
this case it is using the get verb which
is used to clarify that this request
will only receive data that is it won't
be making any changes the server
receives the request that was
transferred from the client there's that
second T the server then does the work
that it needs to do finally it generates
the resulting web page and sends back a
response to the client my browser in
this case the most important part of the
response is the body for a web page that
contains the HTML hypertext markup
language which gives us the remaining
parts the HT of our acronym hypertext is
text that can link to other texts in
HTML we perform that linking with anchor
tags so with that response the browser
renders the page when one of those links
are clicked they kick off a brand new
HTTP get request and the processor
repeats itself over and over in between
those clicks though the protocol is done
we've made the request we got the
response HTTP as it was originally
designed is a stateless protocol once
that request receives a response it's
all done if you want to keep some sort
of State your client will have to manage
that itself and send it up with each new
request check out the notes for more on
this
there are more HTTP verbs also known as
request methods besides get most common
scenario you see is when you encounter a
form that is used to take information
from you typically you'll see the verb
post used to explain that you are a
submitting or posting data to the server
okay so our protocol that's used to
transfer this hypertext is admittedly a
little more complex than our rally chant
was there's quite a bit of important
information in there that is included in
the request and the response you've
probably seen query string parameters
and URLs and you know the stuff after
the question mark this is one way to
pass information about the request
another common way this information is
passed around is through specific key
and value pairs called headers both
requests and responses have headers and
they're used to help further communicate
what is wanted as well as what has been
sent back
some of the popular request headers
allow you to specify information about
the content that you expect back like
the language or the type of content you
can also state that you want the page if
it has changed since a certain time this
technique allows for caching which is a
powerful concept why get the whole page
if you already have it in your local
cache
you can embed authentication information
in each request using a header and this
way you're essentially keeping your
client logged in across requests this
response also contains headers a super
important one is the status code this
lets you know what happened on the
server side and can convey things like
missing documents I'm sure you've seen
the old 404 or maybe the pages moved but
hopefully everything is a 200 okay
it can also explain the content type how
large the data returned is and many more
things
okay got it are you feeling good about
that little Whirlwind tour remember feel
free to make me repeat myself if that
was too much I totally get it that was a
lot of information
it's important to have a basic
understanding of these things because
rest sits on top of them it uses the
concepts that were introduced with the
web to expose resources that can be
accessed and manipulated
let's take a look at how the restful
approach takes advantage of the web and
its tooling for your benefit
profit
rest stands for representational State
transfer apis that meet the rest
architectural style constraints are
considered to be restful now a typical
way to teach about restful apis is to
cover the constraints that Define it all
up front now I don't know about you but
personally I find approaching learning
that way pretty overwhelming especially
from the beginning I mean we haven't
even looked at an API yet on top of that
most of the rest apis that you'll use
will meet all of these constraints so
here's the thing I promise that we'll go
over all the constraints but let's do it
on our own time like don't learn them
all right this instant we could even
make it a fun Journey like a restful
constraint scavenger hunt complete with
prizes
void were prohibited here are the
guiding architectural constraints
required for an API to be considered
restful we'll check them off when we
discuss them and then we'll loop back
once more at the end to review gotta
collect them all sound fun
good
let's get started talking about how rest
API sits on top of web technology like a
little hat much like the web the client
makes a request to a server the client
in this case is typically going to be
your program and you'll probably be
using some sort of library to create the
request to the server
the protocol used you guessed it it's
HTTP and it's stateless the server won't
remember anything about the particular
client if you want to maintain State
like your login details you must send it
with each and every request you'll do
this using headers and just like that we
talked about two of our rest constraints
client server architecture and stateless
you got too knocked off already you're
on a roll
now we should probably talk about what
that request was requesting right well
it most certainly was requesting
information about a resource now a
resource is a little abstract and that's
intentional it's the r in the URL or URI
we use the term resource to reference an
object
also happens to be pretty abstract right
and this is because we can use resources
to describe just about anything that we
build for instance let's imagine an
e-book store website on the home page
there's a list or collection of new
books each of these books is a resource
we click in to take a closer look at
that book resource and we see a link to
the author which is also a resource we
click into the author resource and we
see a collection of all the other books
they've written maybe we even see a
group of fans again another collection
and each of those fans are a resource
clicking into a fan resource we see a
collection of their favorite authors and
books everything is a resource
let's change gears how about an image
sharing application on your phone so we
have user resources and those users post
photos which are resources and those
photos can be loved so there's a lover
resource maybe there's an album that
could be created there's an album
resource that contains photos and albums
have a collection of contributor
resources turns out almost everything we
ever want to build can be expressed in
terms of resources and collections
most of what we want our applications to
be able to do to the resources can be
expressed through the unfortunate
sounding acronym crud and that stands
for creating reading updating and
deleting now as a user of the ebook site
all we did was a bunch of reading
no pun intended
I actually did intend that one we were
reading right just getting information
to display it like we retrieved the
author page we made a read request the
web browser used a get request to the
specific author page the restful API
follows the same logic your program
sends a get request to a URI then the
server responds with data and of course
all the HTTP headers you've come to know
and love the body is typically
represented these days as Json or
JavaScript object notation
Json provides a great way to structure
and Nest your data every programming
language that I can think of provides
some means of turning a Json string into
a native object
the content type is typically something
that you can specify in your request if
Json isn't your thing if you recall
there are other HTTP verbs available
these words are used in rest apis to
clearly State the intention of your
request want to add an author post to
the slash author's endpoint and send the
data that you want to update in the body
of your request now these fields will be
defined for you somewhere want to remove
an author send a delete to that specific
author resource updates typically
support the patch verb and you'll see
we're able to represent our crud needs
the create request update and delete
using HTTP methods pretty cool right
what this means is that you can interact
with any application out there that's
exposed their rest API you could grab
data remotely automate tasks and even
smush together different services
this is called a mashup and here's the
thing there are a ton of apis available
just about anything that you can imagine
and if they're truly restful they'll all
feel pretty much the same you can build
anything there are services that allow
you to do incredible things with just a
few simple API calls so now the question
becomes what are you going to build so
why don't you take a quick break and
when you come back let's explore a
restful API together we'll take a peek
at how to use the music streaming
service Spotify and their excellent
restful API
foreign
you have some Newfound understanding of
how web-based apis work I walked you
quickly through some imaginary rest apis
and now I'm thinking it's time that we
get a little more specific why don't we
go exploring together some of these rest
apis allow you to give it a try from the
comfort of your very own web browser one
of my personal favorites that allows for
exploration is the streaming music
service Spotify so here I am at
spotify.com now a quick word of warning
it is going to look different I
guarantee you this site is going to look
different because they're always making
things better for us for us Spotify
users us lovers of music and as as well
us developers so uh I want you to try
this when you go to a site any site that
you want to you'll see here that this is
really nice Spotify is letting us kind
of test out what it feels like in in the
web on the web page but if I scroll down
to the bottom
that's typically where they hide nerdy
stuff now I knew this was here but if I
didn't I would look around for something
like this this developers and I'm going
to click into here
oh I cannot tell you how good it feels
as a developer to end up in a place
where it feels like you're being taken
care of right this is so nice the
Spotify for developers it looks like it
was thoughtful and I can tell you that
it is very nice it's a very nice tool
um or you can scroll down you can see
all sorts of stuff they give you some
examples of what you might want to do
right what what could you build with
this uh so you could find out like uh
different things like you could use an
API to see uh uh the beats and the
sections and the bars I think that
there's a way to figure out if a song is
danceable or not so that maybe I could
import dancing we'll see
uh and if I scroll back up to the top
here you'll see that there's these
different headings we've got this
discover I think this is great if you're
going to explore things we have this
docs you'll see that there's all types
of different uh actually apis and sdks
software development kits which are apis
which allow you to do different things
you'll see that there's ones for iOS
there's ones for Android what we're
going to be focusing on is the one for
the web API so if I click into that
we'll get a nice overview of what this
is I'm going to blow this up just a
little bit uh so you'll see based on
some simple rest representational State
transfer principles that's our uh that's
what we're doing that's what we're going
through we're going through our um our
scavenger hunt we're going through that
there's a Spotify web API that returns
Json JavaScript object notation about
music artists albums and tracks right so
that's awesome that's great uh so we can
see all sorts of different stuff it uh
it opens up at this api.spotify.com is
the specific URL and then it has a set
of endpoints with each unique path right
each of those URLs that we were looking
at before
there is a way to get um specific data
so you could do this thing for you where
you authorize so I could uh I could be a
user you could see what I recently
listened to I could have a playlist I
could add to it but in order to do that
you need to have uh authorization to be
able to do that you don't want to be
able to just add to anybody's playlist
right so
um there is some authorization that's
available and uh we're not going to do
anything that requires that here so if
you keep on looking down here you'll see
that there's uh it's based on those rest
principles
um and uh you'll see that it does a get
to retrieve resources right and there's
the post to create resources and again
resources here are uh songs and artists
and tracks maybe maybe the resource
you're creating here is one of those
playlists that we talked about uh you
can change using a put and a delete will
delete the resource so awesome right so
it's using rest like we saw
you'll see that Spotify uses this URI
style so it's a Spotify track and then
uh it has this a unique ID this Spotify
ID this will make more sense as we we uh
dig into it a little bit more uh and
then you'll see that there's always this
uh Spotify URL that allows you uh to see
uh what it was and we'll show you this
um as well
as we said the responses come back and
they are a Json object uh and we're
going to be looking here at a tool uh in
in the future called curl which you can
use from your command line that's what
this dollar sign here is talking about
I'll show you all this but basically
it's saying that there's a lot of
artists that come back you don't want
all the artists and it will come back
paginated uh and of course
um you can use caching we'll take a look
at that here you can you can see if uh
the thing has changed or not so we'll
take a look at that
and basically the response that comes
back if everything's good it's going to
say a 200 or these these 200 level uh
accounts and then there's uh bad
requests so if uh if you ask wrong or
maybe maybe it wasn't found that's the
404 or unauthorized if we try to do one
of those playlists uh we get an
unauthorized and there's also if if
you're a developer uh you never want to
see this one it's the 500 it means you
made an error
um uh on the server side uh we won't be
we'd be doing any of those because we're
just going to be hitting somebody else's
code
cool all right so
um Spotify offers the ability to uh you
could look at this and you can build
your own curl request but one of the
really nice things that I love about
their API and you'll you'll find this
happens often if we scroll back up here
to the top sorry if I'm making you sick
there and we're gonna jump in here to uh
what's known as the console
over on the left are the things that we
can do with their API and one of the
things I want to do first is I want to
search
you can see it's making a get to the
search endpoint so I'm going to go into
there and what's really nice is it's set
it up so that we can kind of build the
query that we're looking for so now we
need to decide what we're going to do I
think probably the first uh person that
I would ever search for the first artist
I would search for and you can see that
here it's showing the different values
of what it is I would I would probably
search for Beyonce I mean right wouldn't
you and I could choose is that a track
or an artist so the type there is
important and if I type artist uh you'll
see that what's happening
is you'll see the curl here is changing
it's changing that it says the Q is the
Beyonce so that's one of the parameters
that we're passing into the API and
artist is here and you can see there's
different uh things that we could do
here what's really important is that it
needs to have this oauth token now
what's nice is we can build one of those
even if we don't have a Spotify account
so I'm going to do that I'm going to
click this get token I am not currently
logged in
um and I actually don't have a Spotify
account yet in this uh in this user I do
have a Spotify account I love Spotify
um and this is asking um basically what
you would do is you would create a
specific oauth token if you were ever to
use this API outside of where we're
doing this right now you would you would
create one of these tokens so that you
could log in later and you say what it
is that you want so here's the playlist
right we don't we're not going to do any
of the playlist stuff we're just going
to do a search maybe we'll look up some
of Beyonce's uh Tunes but so I'm gonna
go and click this request token
so now it's asking me to either log in
with my Spotify account which I can or I
can create a new one and let's walk
through that just in case you don't have
a Spotify account already let's create a
new one and this will be my developer
account here
um uh so I'm going to put in my email
so my email I don't know if you know
about this but uh if you use Gmail you
can uh uh you can do a little plus sign
and it will still send to the left side
of your Gmail so I'm gonna do uh at
Spotify sign up and uh that way any
emails I get from here it will have that
and it's a kind of a way to let you have
multiple accounts and I think so again
uh my my Gmail is Craig s Dennis
gmail.com but I'm going to do uh Spotify
sign up
at gmail.com and it will go to my Gmail
it'll just kind of ignore this Gmail
does that for you it's pretty nice right
so I'm going to put in the same password
as my luggage which is one two three
four five six just kidding
uh and uh what should we call you oh
you know what I love it when you call me
Big Papa
that will appear in my profile I am
ready for it and Auntie it is my
birthday on November 19th
uh 19
uh let's see what do I I think for
wouldn't it be nice if I was born in
1999.
um what is your gender oh this is nice
how how nice this is like super
inclusive
um I I love that this is so inclusive
like it's like somebody at Spotify went
and talked to other people and listened
to what people wanted and they included
people who uh who identify as non-binary
or other or prefer not to say so like
wherever you sit in that I love uh and
hats off to you Spotify for uh being
inclusive because inclusivity matters
share my registration data uh sure why
not
I am not a robot
I don't think I am oh oh no uh the
images with bicycles that one's got a
bike
that one's got a bike that one has a
what is that garbage there is that this
is bike lane
uh this is bike okay here we go please
I am not a robot thank you all right so
I'm gonna click sign up
oh I I am male I I I am male so here we
go that is how I identify
all right I'm going to save uh that
login
and I am going to log in with it so here
we go
all right so it's asking me if I have
access to this developer console and it
will see my I'm logged in as big papa
here we go
and now you'll notice here that there is
this token here right this is this oauth
token that got created for me by Spotify
and it's putting it into this console
for me so I can share it now you never
want to let your token out if you get
hold of somebody gets a hold of your
token they can do stuff on your behalf
and I realize that this is on a screen
being recorded and I'm going to get rid
of this token here in a bit so you will
not be able to have it so I've got this
token it's filled out here I'm going to
click try it and we're going to do a
search for Beyonce let's see what
happens
so you will see that we got some
information back so we got a list of
artists because that's the type that I
searched for
um and this is the search that we did uh
we'll see some external URLs that we
think that this is probably her I'm
gonna see I'm gonna I'm gonna grab this
really quick but you can kind of see how
how things are laid out here right so uh
this is my Spotify URL for that let's
see if this is is her
this looks like her yeah yeah definitely
so so great Crazy In Love uh uh cuff it
I haven't heard that one yet awesome so
uh this is Beyonce great so we got her
we've we found her we used this search
um uh it has shows how many followers
she has wow 32 million good job uh it
tells the genre so we could do all sorts
of really cool uh stuff with this and
it's here you'll see that um I'm getting
a URL I'm getting a link that will open
up her specific artist page right so so
here is is her ID so if I take her ID
I'm gonna grab this ID I'm gonna come
over here to artists and I can come in
here and I can show all of the artist's
albums so you'll see It'll be artists
slash ID slash albums let's see all of
the albums that she did but let's look
at that in Json format so uh the artist
that I want I'm just gonna uh pipe pipe
that ID in there from before right now
it still has my Bearer token the console
has done that for me
and I can go ahead and do try it and we
should see that now it's going to return
back albums right so we've made a get
request to the albums and I can see all
of the albums uh that she's had here and
we can see uh where they're available in
different markets as well looks like
she's available and lots of markets all
over the world uh who runs the world all
right so here we go uh we're going to
look let's see uh these are these are
albums
that's the artist there that's the type
of the artist let's get one of the
albums here let's make sure that we got
it so uh you see that it's got different
things like I could get access to maybe
the image of what this album is so let's
do that I'm going to post that here open
that up and let's see there she is on
her horse her her magical horse there
foreign
so that's pretty cool right this is this
is awesome I can get access to all sorts
of information about an artist I can get
by their ID I can go and find all sorts
of different things that I wanted to do
right so so
um uh if I knew an album too once I have
the ID I could get the ID I could get
the tracks
um
all sorts of amazing things and then
there's these playlists right so you can
add a playlist if I wanted to I could
post to create a playlist now of course
I need to authenticate to do that and
that's a little bit outside of what
we're doing here but I could add
um a put together a playlist for for
everybody to do using this API uh and uh
again when we were looking at the
artists
um when we're looking at this git artist
it's showing this curl command and we're
going to take a look at that here in a
bit but I just want to take a little bit
of time I want you to go and take a look
go back to this discover section and
kind of get inspired by what's what's
available right so so you can look at um
there's these different things where you
can you can I was right you can check
and see if there's danceability of a
song you can go and find a track and is
it danceable and you know that Beyonce's
the songs are going to come back uh very
high in the dance ability uh thing there
but lots of powerful things and there's
lots of cool examples that you can do
that people have already gone and built
and you can take a look at how they
built it and how they use the API
recommend foundations this is awesome
really this is like super wide open to
you and uh you can do all of this
because of the apis that they provide
pretty cool right you can get access to
all of spotify's music library and you
can build tools that extend their
platform I highly recommend that you go
and take a look at what other people
have built using these apis it's super
impressive did you notice how fast those
results came back how could it do that
search so quick
oh wait a second does it even need to
those results don't change all the time
it's not like Beyonce is dropping a new
song every minute though I wish you
would those results are definitely
cachable ding ding ding cash ability is
also available on the client and we'll
get to that here in a bit but this is a
great example of a layered system I'm
almost positive that Spotify has set up
things so that it Returns the same Json
from its own server-side caching
mechanism it's not rendered that on
every single request as a user of the
API I don't know how it's doing that and
frankly I don't care I want it to be
available and fast when I hit that
specific URL Beyonce definitely
appreciates how fast the results are
returned she might even take that API
Dev to Red Lobster let's go ahead and
take a quick break during this break I'd
love for you to move around and think
about what you might be able to build
with that Spotify API
for instance
while I was using this API I had this
idea pop up when I'm at a music festival
I often have a hard time deciding which
band I should go see there's so many now
I would love to have an app suggesting
me which of the bands that are currently
playing I would most likely enjoy you
know based on my listening habits I'm
pretty sure that you could build that
just with the Spotify API and using a
list of events of the bands that are
performing and if you do end up building
that share it with me because I need it
what other interests do you have that
provide an API that you can use check
the notes for more ideas now after you
come back from your break let's dive a
little deeper and make use of an API
using our own tools see you soon
no really take a quick break seriously
it'll do you good no binging
[Music]
while I realized that exploring an API
on a website is informative it might not
feel like you're actually using that API
I think the next logical step in
exploring is actually making that
request yourself from your computer not
from a website now as I pointed out in
the Spotify docs there were examples
that were using a command called curl
curl is an open source tool that is used
to send data back and forth and it runs
locally on your computer and it's
awesome for poking around at apis what
do you say we explore it a bit
okay so we are back here on our Spotify
page and we say that there is a command
here that says curl
curl is a command that we can run from
our terminal now if both of those terms
are new to you command and terminal this
is a great time to head over the notes
and learn about what the terminal is so
my operating system is a Mac and it has
an application on it called terminal so
I'm going to open that up terminal and
in fact I'm going to make this a little
bit bigger let's go ahead let's let's
take let it take up the whole screen
we're going to be in here for a little
bit so I'm going to type clear and clear
my window alright so
um uh this terminal allows me to perform
actions on my computer like I could make
it do text-to-speech I can do say and I
can say hi Mom hi Mom
and it says hi Mom
um uh in the Windows operating system
has a terminal as well and while it's a
little bit different they're actually
pretty quite similar uh but check the
notes for more on this so what happens
is I write the command
and then I pass in values for the
parameter in this case it's high mom now
note that I used quotes there because I
want to pass one value even though
there's a space if there was a space
that's kind of how you separate things
but with the quotes of saying this is
one value that I'm passing in
we developers spend a lot of time in our
terminals so if this is new to you I
want you to remember that it was new to
everyone at one time so please take your
time and don't let this get you too
frustrated you've got this
so I already have curl installed I'm
going to just go ahead and make sure
that I Do by typing the word curl and if
I see this I can see that I could type
curl and then the command dash dash help
now if I didn't have this installed if
this came back with like I don't know
what you're talking about when you type
curl the word curl uh that's okay so um
uh we're gonna head over to the notes
and you'll get sorted there but the
starting point where I want you to go is
curl.se so you'll come to this page
you'll see this is a command line tool
in library for transferring data since
1998. that logo sure feels like that
doesn't it uh it does all sorts of
things what we're really concerned about
is this HTTP right we're going to use
this from the command line to get access
to a URL so if you don't have a curl on
your command go ahead and pause me and
check out the notes for the best way to
get this installed on your computer uh
there's a lot of different ways to do it
if you come here under a download you'll
see that there's different uh operating
systems for so you've got your Linux and
you've got your Mac OS and if you come
down here you've got your windows so
there's different ways of getting things
uh installed so go ahead take your time
get that installed and when you come
back I want you to try this I want you
to do this thing with me so I'm going to
go back to my terminal
and I'm going to make sure that it works
uh the way that I always like to test is
I like to go to
um uh I can has dad
joe.com uh how do you get a Bailey alien
to sleep you rock it oh so good anyway
that's how you do that um uh that
that'll let you go and it's going to hit
that website it's going to give you back
a joke when you're ready
so now that we've got our curl up and
running we've got our successful dad
joke let's go ahead and run that command
from Spotify so I'm going to come back
over to my Spotify thing where I was
running the search uh I'm gonna make
sure that it's still working actually
before I get started because these these
tokens Can expire and depending on how
long your break was it might have
expired but mine is still working so I
got this back here and I should be able
to get this from my command line and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
copy this I'm going to highlight this
this is a development practice known by
us developers known as copy pasta so I'm
going to copy this and I am going to go
back to my terminal and I'm going to
paste
um and this long uh list of things here
uh what this is doing is saying hey I
want to make a get request to the
api.spotify.com forward slash V1 search
remember that's where we were at we were
searching and we're passing the query
string of Beyonce and the type of artist
and uh we're telling it hey I would like
to get back uh Json and I am sending you
Json even though we're not actually
sending Json the default has that there
and this is the important one this is
sending you a header right the dash H is
a header an authorization and this is
that long token that we had there now if
all is working when I press enter I
should get here locally on my machine
that uh same list of data that we did
and I did check that out so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to come back up
here and I am going to grab wow there's
a lot of information here right when
this comes back I'm going to grab her ID
and so I remember that when we were
looking at it it was down in here this
ID
is this the right one is that the first
one so we got items uh no this is her ID
here this is her idea it starts with a 6
v w so I'm going to copy that and I'm
going to use that I'm going to go back
and remember I'm going to go and I'm
going to look I want to see what um what
albums uh she has so I'm going to come
into here and I'm going to remember I'm
going to paste this this URL here and
I'm going to run this make sure that
that's still working I'd like you to go
ahead and pause me I think I'd like to
see can you get her albums locally on
your machine can you go ahead and make
sure that you can do the same get
artists see all of Beyonce's albums on
your local machine so here's what we'll
do you give it a try
um and if you uh when once you get it
once you get it printing locally on your
machine
um uh you can let me know and then
unpause me and I'll show you how I did
it okay are you ready you got this pause
me
thank you
[Music]
cool so how'd you do so here's probably
one way that you could have done it is
just copied that right copy this whole
thing and pasted it but what I want to
show you is that we have access to we
know what these these these URLs are
right so we know that there's this V1
artist and in fact uh we can see that
there is a git of uh Slash V1 artists
and then you can actually pass their ID
in the in the URL there right that's
what this ID is here so let's let's just
go back I'm going to show you a little
trick too so um I've I've got her ID
copied still um so I could have just
just ran that query and copied the curl
and pasted it here and if you did that
you did it right I just want to show you
a little bit more of what else how else
we could explore so I'm going to press
the up arrow and you'll see
um my cursor is moving here um I'm going
to press the option key on Mac I think
it press the ALT key on Windows you can
jump around like this and I'm going to
get rid of what's here and I'm going to
say V1 artists
right so that's the collection of
artists and I have that specific ID
right so there's the ID and I'm going to
press enter here you'll see that I got
back Beyonce which is awesome that's
what I did and then remember the the
artists have I'm gonna go to the front
of the line that's Ctrl a on a Mac uh
and I'm gonna switch this so artists
have uh this is a specific artist so
Beyonce and we want to see Beyonce's
slash albums which is what the the
console would have uh generated for you
but I just wanted to show you that you
can kind of navigate and move through
and you'll see that there's a there's a
bunch of different information that
comes through here
um it's kind of hard to see right so so
um kind of hard to parse
and this is something optionally that
you can do so I press the up arrow and
I'm going to press pipe that into a tool
called JQ and uh you'll see that it
comes back very nice and pretty right so
um this is something that that is very
nice to have uh and I piped that that's
this this uh the symbol above uh the the
enter key is this pipe symbol and it
allows you to take whatever happened in
this first part of the command and take
its results and put it in this part of
the command which is super cool
um and again this is in the notes you
don't need to you don't need to worry
about this but I know that I can query
things so I can say that of the items
I'm only interested in the name uh the
dot name from each one of the items and
this is a little query language that's
attached to this JQ uh program you don't
need to do this this is just something
if you're doing it from the command line
it's something that we do that we could
kind of hack around with a little bit
you'll see I can get all the the lists
of her albums and that's pretty cool
right that's powerful and if you are
going to just start poking around and
moving around with the URLs one thing I
wanted to make sure that your cautious
of is if we come back and we take a look
at the the console page here they do a
nice trick for you for back here in
search like one of the things that I
want to make sure uh I know that Beyonce
has this song that's like something like
who runs the world right who runs the
world girls but I don't remember where
what album it's on so I'm gonna search
for a type track and now note that my
query has spaces here now what's
happened here is it's done this uh URL
encoding so like if you were trying to
to mess around and work with the search
you'd want to make sure that whatever
you did you passed that uh with those
those plus signs there so I'm gonna run
that curl command and we'll see who runs
the world girls and I'm going to uh I
see there's this uh this open link here
so I'm going to go ahead I'm going to
open that let's take a look uh and make
sure this is the right track I'm pretty
sure it is
it is not the right track what is this
Kim maybe maybe some other some others
so let's take a look well that that's
interesting so uh oh I just went to the
bottom instead of going to the top so I
should have went to the very top of
these results
or I should have pulled probably pulled
the name out rockabye baby there's a
Rockabye Baby version of this whoop okay
so when the color stops
hope you're not getting sick all the
scrolling so Beyonce is the artist that
we want so this is the one we want to
hear this song Let's see if I got the
right one this time that was just
something you know there's a lot of data
coming back here it's kind of hard to do
to use on the command line sometimes I'm
a little clutzy like you just saw
here we go let's let's see what happens
let's make sure this is it
there it is there's Beyonce
not the song I was looking for oh yeah
it is who runs the world girls and now I
can listen to that so it's like who runs
the world girls it's kind of like who
runs the terminal curl
boy that was a that was a big setup just
to make that joke I hope that you
enjoyed it you can has that joke curl is
an awesome way to explore apis and
you'll find that often just like we saw
with Spotify apis will use Curl in their
docs to show you how they work Spotify
is just one API and there's so many
companies and services out there in fact
some apis are the product like that's
what the company selling to us
developers so now that we've been
building up those muscles why don't we
take a swing at another API
let's use a different API this time
let's use twilio twilio is a company
that loves apis in fact that's what the
company started as more than a decade
ago just a set of apis it started as
abstracting away communication channels
and by that I mean any way you'd ever
possibly want to communicate with your
users want to send a text message
there's an API call for that want to
make a phone call there's an API send an
email a WhatsApp message literally
whichever way you want to communicate
there's an API for all of them
developers embed these apis into their
apps and I'm pretty sure that you've
probably used it without even knowing
you were nowadays there's a whole Suite
of products that twilio offers that they
saw their customers needing but under
the covers it's still these apis that
are powering everything
I need to be a little upfront here with
you I love twilio I mean I love it so
much I even applied for a job with them
and I got it but even if they didn't
hire me I know that I'd still show off
how powerful their apis are I mean with
a single command you can send a text
message I remember when I first did that
I was like
like that level of abstraction is
amazing I mean if you've never thought
about it before what even is a text
message I mean I know I have an app on
my phone and I can use it to communicate
with literally anyone else but how does
that work like there's all those
different cell carriers and standards
and phone numbers I mean I I have no
idea and with twilio I don't need to
know that's the beauty of this API it
just works here let me show you all
right so here we are at twilio.com and
again a word of warning this is going to
look completely different from my right
now to your right now uh so please make
sure that you check the notes for
anything that might have changed and is
specifically about this flow that we're
about ready to do is we're going to sign
up for a trial account so I'm going to
click the sign up button here and this
is going to look completely different I
know because our team is constantly
making this better but the one thing
that I want to make sure that you know
right now is that you see that there is
no credit card required and it is a free
twilio account so I'm going to put my
information in here
and I'm going to use the same trick that
I used uh before where I do plus and I'm
going to say API course V2 at gmail.com
so I uh the plus side there again a
little Gmail trick
um uh we're gonna go ahead and I'm gonna
put in my password again uh one two
three four five six my luggage how many
times can I do that joke and then uh
would I do this except uh must be 16 or
more characters okay
there's some password requirements over
there
I think that's 16. all right uh here we
go
starting my free trial
I'm ready let's do this
I'm definitely going to save that long
password because I need that for later
all right so I have now uh should have
been sent an email so let me make sure
that I got that email
and I did I am going to click the link
to verify it and here we go I'm going to
verify my phone number uh to verify I'm
a human because all humans have phones
so we're gonna do 432 uh five two seven
four two seven four please don't call
too late uh I'm gonna try that I'm going
to click verify all right so I got my
verification code hey that came very
quickly that's wonderful my verification
code uh is 017
869 uh hopefully your code's different
than that wouldn't that be funny if
they're all the same
all right so here we go so which product
are we here to use we're going to use
SMS we're going to use the SMS messaging
product and what do we plan to build uh
let's see uh of course these questions
are going to be different uh what I'm
going to do we're gonna build um
what about something else we're gonna
build something else uh we how do we
want to build with with uh twilio with
code right so we're going to end up
writing code if we want to with minimal
code on top of code samples or no code
at all so uh definitely don't need code
to build over here but I'm going to say
with code because we're we're developers
here
um so what is your preferred coding
language we're going to do JavaScript
even if it's not uh we're going to be
doing JavaScript for the rest of this uh
course and I do want to host my code on
twilio which is nice there's a nice
serverless option
of these options like I said are totally
going to change just try to answer them
as truthfully as you can so um my
building country is United States uh
which is true and I'm going to get
started
I'm going to go ahead and walk this I
guess let's go ahead and so we'll um I
can explore products there's way more
products that are available than you can
see here this is what got built based on
the menu of what they thought but if I
ever want to I can come to this explore
products and get more uh we probably
won't need to do that because we filled
out what we're gonna do
um and this is where you can get access
to your logs I'll show that off here in
a bit if there's any problems you'll be
able to find them there uh manage your
account keys and build trust with your
customers yeah we can build all sorts of
different uh things in here we probably
won't need to do too much here because
most of the keys that we have are
available to us right from this page
that we're on actually so we'll keep
going uh and I can see the billing and
again uh you're in a trial account and
you think you get something like fifteen
dollars uh to try with so we'll be
sending text messages using that that uh
trial dollar bills y'all ah so here we
go uh and then you can switch between
products so you can have multiple
accounts right so if you wanted to come
and like explore a little bit do your
own personal thing maybe do something
for work later up to you there's a 1550
is what we got all right so
um and then I'll click next
and uh then I can anytime I want to I
can look at this tour again to help
navigate around which is really nice
beautiful console
um so uh we could definitely go ahead
and uh the first thing that we want to
do is we want to get a twilio phone
number
so I'm gonna do that I'm going to click
this get twilio phone number
and I am so glad that this happened to
me it says that this account has been
restricted from provisioning new phone
numbers uh which means it thinks that I
might be spam and you know why it is
it's because I put that Gmail account
with a little plus thing there so if
this happens to you I don't want you to
feel offended or anything like that I
want you to check the notes for the
latest ways uh to get around this and
also I'm going to go right now and I'm
going to email compliance review at
twilio.com and I should get that up and
running if this happened to you go ahead
uh press pause check the notes Here uh
for for what to do and I'm going to uh
actually uh do that I'm going to press
pause here I'm going to get my account
able to uh get a phone number and I will
see you back here in one second all
right so I got all sorted out so I sent
my email to the compliance uh folks and
I was able to say that I was doing a
personal account and I'm learning how to
use these apis and they were able to let
me get in here so uh what I'm going to
do now is when I click this get a twilio
phone number we're not going to see that
message because I'm coming in
and I've got a new phone number and it
automatically gave me this one this one
here this 561 uh it went away really
quick but it's down here this is my this
is my my twilio phone numbers is
561-816-5433 now this number is mine
which is awesome I can use this uh
message I can send messages I can
receive messages I could do all sorts of
things with this I could make calls I
can receive calls this twilio phone
number is mine uh play with I think we
should do just that we should send a
text message now before we get started I
want to make sure that you know this
this stuff you are on a trial account so
there are some limitations you can only
send messages and make calls to verified
phone numbers so when we set things up
we verified like I'm able to send a text
to myself because I verified my phone
number
um and it will say sent from my twilio
account beforehand uh and there's more
things about your trial account too if
you wanted to get into that so so uh
check the notes uh because this this
very well could have changed but check
the notes for for more on this
so let's do it let's send a short
message service and SMS so I'm going to
click here on this docs and support I'm
going to click this it's going to open
up I'm going to go to these developer
docs these developer docs are some of
the best that are available out there uh
I want you to to see these so I would
come here under SMS because that's what
we're doing right short message service
and uh under here under these these
sides on the the docks here you can
collapse these so I'm going to come in
here under API reference I'm going to go
to this message resource
now um this is a this is an API right so
we're in the API reference so the API
that we want to do is we want to be able
to send a from and uh we want to say
from the phone number that we just got
and we want to send a message to my
phone number right so uh we're gonna do
that and you'll you'll see that over
here on the right
um there are uh things that you can do
that that show you what you can do so
with this message we can do all these
different things uh we'll start with
create a message we'll create a message
first so we're going to go uh into this
create a message and uh there's these
different languages here so we have
node.js and you can see the style that
it looks like we'll take a look at
something like this here uh real shortly
this is a helper library that wraps
around the API so you don't need to do
the sorts of things that uh uh we're
about ready to have to do you can you
could do things a little bit more
cleanly but what we're going to look at
is curl right so here's our friend Curl
we're gonna jump over here to curl and
uh the docs have this really nice thing
where I'm able to actually copy this so
I'm going to click uh to copy this and
I'm going to pop over to my terminal all
now again I'm running on a Mac so
there's a couple of things here that
this is assuming that it's going to be
okay because I am running on a Mac it's
going to assume uh that these slashes
see these slashes at the end here
um these uh in on a Mac terminal these
show that we are in the new we're making
a new line available here and also
you'll see that there's these account
SIDS and these auth tokens this dollar
sign twilio auth token dollar sign
twilio account said
um in my terminal on my Mac that is
what's known as an environment variable
and they've been set now
um I don't have those set currently
because I just built this account so
what I'm going to do is
um what kind of bad practice actually
I'm going to actually put my real uh
information here for us to use so so
back back here on our console on our
twilio console you'll see that I have
this thing here called this account Sid
or string identifier so this is my ID my
my unique ID for the account that I just
created so I'm going to go ahead and I'm
going to click this copy button so I
copied that I'm going to come back here
and I'm going to move my mouse and I'm
going to remove right here where it says
account Sid so that's string identifier
I'm going to paste this so that is the
way that twilio is identifying who I am
I'm going to go backwards through the
rest of these and so if you're watching
here on Windows let's just go ahead
let's get rid of these uh these new
lines here so I'm going to just put them
all on one line uh we can handle that
we'll do that so
I'm gonna uh get rid of that line and uh
that way it will work uh completely on
uh both both Windows and Mac uh for what
we're trying to do so I still have my
account Sid here so I'm going to keep on
backing up here
uh and I'm going to get rid of that line
there we go and you'll see one more time
here there's the twilio account Sid that
string identifier for my account was
still present so I'm going to paste that
there so now the API call that I'm doing
is to that specific account it's due to
this messages and you'll note that it's
doing now it's doing a post so because
we're creating something new right so
we're using post to create a message
and you'll see here that it says from
equals and the number actually there for
the from we want that to be the twilio
number that we just got right so that
new one that we just got we're going to
say that is sent from
and let me go back
I'm going to copy my twilio phone number
right so I've got my my 561 number there
and I'm going to paste that here
so uh
yeah from
and the this plus 561 that's a U.S
number so it's got the the it's called a
10 digit long code 10 DLC so it's five
six one eight one six five four three
three is the number that I just bought
and uh we're gonna say by default it
said hi there
um the body of the message right so
instead of that whatever we're going to
do and note that this is all in quotes
and we're going to say Ahoy world I
don't know if you know this or not but
the the first word the way that we used
to answer the phone
um was uh we'd say the phone ring and
you'd be like Ahoy and the other side
would go Ahoy Hoy so we like to do that
here a lot we say a hallway world uh
it's kind of like the hello world of
this so the body of the message the text
that we're going to get uh is going to
say Ahoy world
and then we're going to send it I'm
going to send it to my phone number
um so this is this is one of those
numbers that you verified right when you
created your account you verified that
you had a number so my phone number is
5432-527-4274 don't text too late at
night please
um and then the final thing that we have
here is this auth token now this is a
very private key right we don't ever
want anybody to have access this was
like that Spotify token that we had
right we don't ever want anybody to have
it I am going to I trust you uh and I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm gonna paste that
here uh so that we have it so
um uh that is uh something that you
never want to let out because now you
could seeing this on my screen you could
use this right
um and uh you probably don't want
anybody doing that so you never want to
actually give that number out you want
to hide that and we'll talk about how to
do that more here in the future but
right now I just wanted to show you
we're going to use Curl we're going to
create we're going to send a post to
this URL here and you'll notice that
ends in Json so that's what we're going
to get back that's the way that it works
this is to my account my account said
you see it starts with this AC
um and and we're going to post uh using
this data URL encode so the way that the
twilio API works is it takes um some
parameters it takes from body and two
and the way that you pass those in curls
with this dash dash data URL encode and
you pass what it is that you want to
have uh go across here so we're gonna if
all of this works I should get a message
back uh I should get a text message on
my actual phone uh that says Ahoy world
let's do
and it looks like I'm missing a quote
someplace so where is the quote that I'm
missing
I don't see a missing quote
[Music]
if I can go press the up Arrow maybe it
will show up yeah oh right you know how
many times I do that
the Ahoy world the exclamation point uh
is is uh something you need to typically
Escape so I'm just going to say Ahoy
world with a single quote there so if uh
if you're having that problem sorry
that's what that was so I pressed the up
Arrow to get my information back uh
there and now if all is going well and I
press send we should get a text here we
go and so I got this message back I got
this and sure enough here it is I got it
and you can see here it says at the
front of the body uh that it sits it
says Ahoy it says a scent from your
twilio trial account which is fine we're
in a trial count that's totally fine but
I did and boom I got it on my actual
phone I got that message which is
awesome we now have the ability uh to
send a text message from the command
line right that's pretty cool
let's take this a step farther actually
so we know that uh that that API when I
did a post I was able to uh get
information back I'm going to go ahead
now and I'm gonna do uh just bring that
back and I'm gonna get rid of all of
these parameters here
um I'm going to get rid of the from the
body and the two and I'm going to change
I'm gonna make that I'm going to do a
get
and let me show you what that looks like
so I'm going to get rid of all of those
parameters I'm going to keep that same
URL and it still has my account Sid
there right in there and instead of a
post what we're going to do is we're
going to do a get what we should do is
we should get back all of the messages
that are there so I'm going to hit this
kind of like a message log right so
these are all the messages that have
been sent uh which is awesome here it is
sent from your twilio trial account so
and actually I can make this look a
little bit prettier like we saw with JQ
again totally optional in the notes if
you want it but yeah there we go so you
can see that I've got some information
uh that's sent back here and you can see
that the the message that was sent it
was sent outbound uh to my phone number
to me from that number which is awesome
right and like I said curls a little bit
uh challenging because it's going to be
a little bit different if you're in
Microsoft Windows or if you're in Mac I
tried to make that as comfortable as
possible but you saw that I did run into
a couple of things like I couldn't use
the exclamation point and things like
that and it's a little clumsy so
um stay tuned because there are more
tools coming your way awesome job
getting that run running from your local
machine it feels pretty good doesn't it
what a cool skill you have now you can
send a text message from your machine
with just a single command now believe
me this is just the tip of the iceberg
of what you can do there are so many
more twilio apis available and now I
know that you can explore them with curl
for now though let's take things another
step deeper now I don't know about you
but I'm a little clumsy when it comes to
Long commands on the terminal like we
just did with curl when exploring apis I
really like to lean on visual tools if
you don't mind I'd love to show you some
that is of course right after you take a
quick break
[Music]
foreign
there are a few tools that I Rely Upon
when it's time for me to explore new
apis and I thought I'd share them with
you I use these to dive in and get my
hands dirty and organize my learnings
one of the most famous tools and one
that you've probably already heard of is
called Postman do you get it post man in
addition to being a pretty good Pun It's
also a Powerhouse of features
Postman started as a Chrome extension
that let you make API calls and what
it's turned into is a powerful
Enterprise ready tool with all sorts of
bells and whistles and even shareable
collections for the most popular apis
that are out there it's jam-packed full
of features and in my humble opinion you
probably don't need all that just yet in
your Learning Journey there are entire
courses on how to properly wield its
power and I've linked to a few of those
in the notes there are other tools
popping up all the time that allow you
to explore apis and store your notes I
like to think of these apps as the
built-in the vein of Postman there's a
whole genre of video games that gets
dubbed metroidvania because they're
similar to Metroid and Castlevania now
these apps are
Postman Amy postmate postman-esque
let me show you an example I just bought
this lamp here it's rad it's from Govi
and it's got this app that I can use to
control it on my phone I can change the
colors right and I could even make it
dance to my beatbox
but
it also has an API these are the docs
here and as I explore these docs I'm
going to save them in one of these
postman-esque tools that I've been using
lately called rest Fox
like here I can see all of the devices
that are associated with my Govi account
and I set that up using this URL here
and you'll see that it is a get request
and I pressed send and it sent the
request and I got back uh the
Govi devices that are associated with my
account
this API requires a header and it's
called Govi API key and you'll see these
double mustaches here that I'm using
this side little mustache thing uh this
is using things from my environment it's
a special key that I don't want anybody
to see I'll show you more of these here
in a bit now notice how this is a get so
I can send the request and you'll see
that here's my response and I can also
get the current state so I have a
different call here I could get the
current state endnote that if I click
Send here we can see that this is the
color of my light currently and I can
also turn it on
or turn it off
and I can turn it on
and I can also change the color right so
I'm going to turn this to to Red you
don't have to turn the
red light on Roxanne
pretty cool right and I have this here
for me whenever I want to tweak things
when I want to come back later and when
I want to use it in my code
did you just have a light bulb moment I
quite literally just did let's see if we
can't build one of these for the twilio
apis so if you'd like to get rest Fox
installed please check the notes this is
an open source tool and it's getting
better every day now if you love it too
I highly suggest that you start if you
click up here you could go and you can
actually check out the GitHub repo and
you can see cute little fox here and
you'll see over here how it's tagged oh
it's tagged rest client I guess maybe
that's a little bit better than my
metroidvania analogy uh maybe rest
client's a good thing API client that's
also a good thing so there's lots of
these tools that are available but let's
start using this one
so I've got rest fox running here
and you'll see I've got the Govi folder
which I can collapse
and typically what I do is group these
by the API that I'm exploring so let's
keep poking around a little bit with
twilio so what I'll do is I'll make a
new folder called twilio so I'm going to
right click over here and make a new
folder called twilio and now in here
we'll create a new request so I right
clicked new request and I'd love to
explore more of the SMS API so let's see
uh oh you know what this new number that
we just bought this twilio number that
we bought not only can It send messages
but it can also receive them so we could
send it a message let's do that so let's
go ahead and send a text to your number
now if you forgot your number it's over
in your console so if you come to your
console and you scroll down a little bit
here you'll see my twilio number so go
ahead and send a text to your number now
my number I'm going to send a number
it's five six one eight one six five
four three three I'm gonna send it yo
and uh uh there we go it went and I
ended up getting a default message back
um and we could change this we could
make we could program this to do
whatever uh but I'll show that off later
but for now uh I just want you to know
that we created a new message uh by
sending to this this API and we can
actually get it
um and you can also find your phone
number later here under those phone
numbers if you go to phone numbers
manage active numbers uh you can see
your phone number and remember outside
of trial mode you could buy multiple
numbers so that's an important uh thing
to know here
so all right so we're going to look at
the incoming messages so uh we should do
that we should call the request what
it's going to be we'll call this
incoming message log that sounds good
and we'll click create
okay so let's head over to the docs and
see how we might do this with so back in
the docs here on the message resource
remember this is where we did the create
a message I'm going to see if there's
something else down in here ah list all
messages that's a good one but we don't
want all of the messages we actually
want to filter it a little bit so look
here we can do this by by matching
filter criteria that's great so we're in
here I'm under the curl tab right I
could be in these different ones but
this this is the example that we want
here I'm going to grab this URL you're
gonna see all of this so that's how
they're filtering there's some stuff
here at the end I'm gonna grab all of
this and I'm going to copy it I'm going
to come back over
and I am going to paste it here in this
enter request URL I'm going to paste the
whole thing there
and it was a get request and uh the URL
had some stuff in this query string that
came afterwards in a query string is you
know defined by this question mark so we
don't want this date sent let's get rid
of this
and what's next we don't we don't want
from right we don't we want to look at
all the numbers that was sent to right
so this is the 2 here is what we want
now this 2B here just happens to be a uh
percent to be URL encoder happens to be
a plus
and I know that and I just happen to
know that without having to Google it
but that's that's a little rough to know
like how do I make a plus sign in in
here
um wouldn't it be nice if this tool just
did all of this URL encoding for us like
we didn't need to make this mess at the
end
well check this out here's query right
here this is what we want so we want to
add this query we don't want to have
this whole stuff at the end here we want
to put in uh two we're going to add a
one of those things there we'll put in a
two so that's going to append that query
string for me and I'm going to put in uh
uh the to my phone number which again my
willio phone number uh which is over
here
in my logs
uh right here actually I can I'm going
to grab this number this is my my twilio
number I'm going to put it in the format
uh that is wanted there
in my rest Fox here we go so I'm gonna
it's that and we're gonna get rid of uh
let's make sure that's one five six one
there we go got rid of all those all
right
now also remember that this was accounts
and then it had account Sid right so
that's the the ID for my account and
then it's under messages there's a
collection called messages underneath
this account said but what we want here
is we want that was uh using an
environment variable from curl
um but this is also known as a path
variable right a path parameter so here
down here we have this path parameters
so the way that these work actually uh
to to replace them is if we go like this
if I get rid of this and I put a colon
what's going to happen is we can
anything that's down here and this path
parameter will replace what's here so
let's do that let's add this item and
again that is twilio account Sid so
that's the name of the the variable
that's up here right is colon twilio
account said that was just what's there
let's keep it because that's what it is
and then we're going to put our accounts
in there so that also is on my console
so I'm going to flip back uh to my
console and on the main page here
you come in you can come down and you
can grab your account Sid so now I have
my account said and I'm going to paste
that there
awesome
and I think we're ready I'm going to
press send and uh oh we got an error we
got a 401 unauthorized uh no credentials
provided oh that's right of course we
want to log in we don't want anyone just
being able to see these messages so we
want to make sure that we have some
authentication happening
so I'm going to head over to the auth
tab you'll see that if I slide this back
and forth I don't know how much screen
real estate you have but you can you can
slide these kind of around as need be uh
so I can I'm going to pull this and
you'll see that when I do my my little
menu here uh collapses uh so I'm going
to choose auth from here but that that
is also available in uh the header here
right so like it's just a different view
of it
all right so in the off I'm going to put
in a basic off and I'm going to put in a
username which is my username and then
I'm also going to put in
uh my password Which is my auth token
over here and again this is very private
and you would never ever want to do this
uh you now know my auth token I don't
want you to have that
um uh and uh because uh you could do
exactly anything you wanted to to my
account now that we're there and one of
the things that you could do is see the
messages that were sent in and look
there's my yo my yo message has made it
in
um
awesome so uh
also I wanted to show you the request
that happened let's take a look at that
you can see that what actually happened
was it was a get that was sent with the
account Sid right and so that was the
account said that we used from if we
look back at the query parameters here
the account said uh showed up there and
then uh it automatically did a two URL
encoded and if you look it put the
question mark in for us and it did that
percent 2B for us automatically URL
encoded very nice right
and we can see the headers that were
sent and we can also take a look let's
look again at this preview so we see
that we had uh the the response came
back and this is Json right so we have a
key called messages and this messages
has this uh it starts out there could be
multiple messages here right so this is
a the start of what's known as a list or
an array and then there's an object in
the start of the object is always done
with one of these mustaches and we call
those mustaches because if you kind of
turn your head sideways it looks like a
mustache so uh all between the opening
mustache and the closing mustache is the
information about
um the messages
right so here's the and there's the
closing uh bit of my list there's only
one this is the closing mustache there
and uh so part of the message that we
can see we could see who uh it was two
that's that's my twilio phone number
here and we could see the from there's
my phone number there please don't call
too late uh but that's my phone number
uh and I did say I said yo to it which
is awesome so now we have this now this
step is completely optional this is
something that I like to do uh is I like
to take notes all right so there's this
incoming message log I like to keep
notes and I put those in the description
over here and so uh uh let's see uh this
returns
all incoming
well let's let's be a little bit more
all messages uh sent to this phone
number
right and uh one of the things that I
like to do is I like to put on uh the
docs here so if I ever come back and I
want to find how was it that I learned
how to do that I could come go and look
uh and put a link there so I'm going to
go flip back over to those docs real
quick
uh and this is read a message with
matching a filter I'm going to copy this
link I'm going to grab this or click
this here so that then it changed the
URL up here when I copy this and this is
what I'm going to store in my notes
again this is totally optional and this
is just notes for you for later because
you could end up having a whole bunch of
these and you might not remember how you
found how to do that if there's
something specific or strange about the
API that you wanted to know I keep the
notes in there and it's a just a handy
learning tool and again totally optional
so we've got our first entry all set and
I think we should add another one why
don't we create the send message one
right so the one that we did before we
sent messages let's do that so I'm just
going to duplicate this because it's got
a bunch of the information that I
already need in it so I'm going to
duplicate it and uh what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to duplicate and I'm
going to say uh send message
right
so uh when we sent a message before
remember it wasn't a get
it's a post so I'm going to change
um I'm going to change that from a get
to a post so now we've got this send a
message that's a post uh and uh the
query string I don't uh want to send a
query string anymore right so remember
we before when we did this we sent it
using the the data URL encode in fact
let's go let's pop back over there and
look at what it was that we did so in
the documentation uh over here we have
this uh create a message resource so so
on the message resource page uh here we
can look and we can go to this create a
message
resource and uh there's some information
about it so you send this HTTP post and
you can see that again we remember
before we do this data URL encode we
were doing this URL encoded so it's this
form encoding is What's Happening Here
and oh look
a couple things actually there's a nice
warning here that says if you want to
send messages while in trial mode you
must verify your two numbers so if you
wanted to send to somebody else you
could put them in this verified caller
IDs if you wanted to you could send to
somebody else as well
um just just there that's how you do
that if you wanted to test or show
somebody what you're building
um that's that's how you do that uh
after of course after you're not in
trial mode you could send it to whoever
you would like to
so
um when we are creating a message we
must include the two right we need that
and we need the from so we'll do either
and we'll do body and there's this media
URL which means I can send a picture
let's let's do that let's make it so
that it sends a picture now when I am in
rest Fox over here
um I don't want to use the query anymore
I'm going to keep the path because a
path is the same right so we're going to
do uh we're gonna do a post to that same
URL twilio account slash uh account said
messages.json and we're going to make a
post to it instead of making a list and
retrieving we're going to create so uh
we're going to go under body and for the
body we're gonna make it form URL
encoded uh and what we want to do there
is we want to send it to so I'm going to
send this uh to my number again don't
call too late five two seven uh four two
seven four
um no really uh if you want to call and
get feedback that's fine
um I'd love to chat
um so we'll do from
and that is uh my number again this is
my number and uh
uh which was that number so we can come
here into the message log we can go pull
that number from the query string so
this is my uh twilio number there
um
uh from is this value there and we are
going to add uh the body the body will
say uh sent
from rest Fox
and let's add our media URL and I just
happen to have one of my favorite photos
which you will have to
um
check out for yourself
um to know what it is but it is a photo
that I pick if you will that I'm going
to uh send to myself
um it's also in the notes if you want to
do this as well if you want to copy that
and paste that so here we go I am going
to do a send now remember I'm also
authenticated with my my username and
password because that copied across when
I did it so I'm going to do a two from a
body and a media URL so now I'm going to
go ahead and click Send and boom we got
our message back right so the response
we got a 201 created right so it was
created uh in the body we could see the
body of our message the key is sent from
rest Fox uh it's got some information we
can go ahead and get access to that uh
message if we wanted to and it's got
these actual uh media resources down
here which we can also take a look at
and we could if we wanted to open up a
whole another one of these and explore
and see what that looked like let's
let's take a look at that in a new tool
before we do go to look at that new tool
one thing that I don't love about what
we just did are um in my in these
requests and these separate requests
these these uh these These are
duplicated right they've got this
username and password if I go to my post
uh send message I've got this username
and password and they're duplicated
there which isn't great right that's not
that's not excellent
um uh one of the things and one of the
tools that most of the these rest
clients provide is a thing called an
environment and let's set that up really
quick real quick for this um so if I
come here under this environment here is
my default uh collection and I can add a
new environment I'm going to add one for
twilio now the way that these work uh
are they are
Json based so uh this is remember this
is the start of an object now if you've
never written Json before take your time
use some patience one of the things that
you could do is you could come in and
you can put in account Julio account Sid
and uh you do the key and then you do a
colon and you can see that I'm this is
unexpected Json down here it's helping
me out
um and now I'm going to put in my
account Sid and again let me go copy
that one more time and I don't have to
copy this anymore because it will be
part of my environment it will be here
with me which is really nice so come
over here I'm going to paste that and
now I want to add a new key so the way
Json works is you put a comma after that
right I'm going to put a new uh the new
key here and we'll do a twilio uh
account or off
again and again this is uh that can be
that key can be whatever you want it to
be and we'll be able to reference it so
I'm going to come and grab my auth token
and I'm going to change this right so uh
that's a great use case of this is I
don't want you to be able to
uh I am going to change this right so as
soon as as soon as I'm done recording
this I'm going to change my auth token
and that would mean that I'd have to go
change each one of them but now I have
one place where it's defined I have one
place in my environment that's defined
so I have this environment here that
says twilio now instead of username I
can do this mustache mustache and I can
say twilio
uh account
Sid and uh that's the way the templating
language works here and then most of
these rest clients
um and you can do uh twilio uh token so
when you see that that's what's
happening that is the environment it's
using the environment variables I'm
going to go do that for here
and also I'm going to copy my auth token
for here and so now I only need to
change that in one place in my
environment
um and
uh you can also use it here so like not
like before I can I can also put my
account Sid here
um so that will also make this so that
it's shareable right so
um if I don't specify my information in
here I can share it so you what you
could do and actually why don't you try
to do it why don't you try to add your
twilio phone number and uh see if you
can figure out how to add to your Json
there uh your twilio phone number and
then you could replace it right you
could replace it here with your uh with
your from from your twilio phone number
uh pretty neat right so that's a good
that's a good little trick that you
could do and here you can do your twilio
phone number you could use it there too
so anything that you're using is
something that you can kind of store
there in your environment and what's
nice about that let's make sure that it
still works
yep it's still working and let's make
sure to make sure my oh I'm gonna send
another picture to myself that's fine
um so uh we know that this environment
is now working and it's here and I don't
need to go back and get those every
single time uh really handy and what's
nice is you could do these imports and
exports and we'll take a look at that
here in a bit so uh when we get back
we're going to take a look in a
different Tool uh because this is rest
Fox and I know that you're probably
getting ready for a rest so let's take a
quick Break
um and then let's see if we can't
retrieve that pick that I sent myself
via this API but let's do that in
another Postman Nanny uh their rest
client right after quick break that is
[Music]
down now
all right quick refresher we had just
sent a message from rest Fox a rest API
client uh here's the body of the message
we did sent from restfox and we actually
sent across some media with it you can
see here it has this num media one
because uh each text message can have
multiple uh Medias attached and if you
scroll down here you'll can see that
there is this uh key of sub resource
Uris and it has a list of um an object
here and one of the objects is for media
and what this will do is this will allow
whatever's at this URL will give us the
accounts for this account for this
message specifically it'll give us all
of the media that is listed now
um typically when I have something
that's uh this far out we could actually
add another one here but I thought I'd
show you a little bit of how my process
normally works in case you wanted to see
what that felt like
so I use an editor called Visual Studio
code it's free it's available and this
is where I do my coding from so I start
I start here I start working on my
coding I would love for you to go ahead
and download this because I want to show
you a tool that's inside here that will
allow us to do a rest client as well
so go ahead and pause me get Visual
Studio code installed and once you do
come back and I'll show you something
[Music]
thank you
okay so uh once you get Visual Studio
code up and running if you press command
shift p there is a thing called
extensions and this will do a little if
you type in install extensions you can
come here and you can see different
things that are available what I want
you to install is a thing called Thunder
we're going to install a thing called
Thunder client and it's this one here
it's a lightweight rest API client for
vs code it's really powerful and the
good news is is it is postman-esque you
are going to feel very familiar when you
take a look at this so uh if you do it
you go ahead and click install and what
will happen is there'll be a little
Thunder client that will install over
here like so
uh and just like you've seen before
there are these this concept of uh
Collections and we can make a new one so
I'll make a new collection uh for twilio
uh and typically what I'm doing is I'm
coding and I run into this API I'm like
oh I wonder what this is uh I'm gonna go
uh explore it a little bit I'll explore
it right from my editor right so I write
my code here and then I can come over
here and just take a look at uh what was
there and so uh let's go back to rest
Fox and I'm gonna grab that rest Fox
that we had here right so we're gonna do
that and then grab that and I'm gonna
come back over here to uh twilio I'm
gonna make a new request I get to name
it and this was the media check uh let's
no we're gonna do all media all media
for a specific message right
uh so here we go I'm gonna paste that
URL in here and of course it's missing
that first part which was uh API dot
twilio.com uh so again this is the going
for that account to those messages
um I'm gonna look here at where it says
off so it says inherit authentication
values from parent this is a very nice
thing this is something that postman has
too uh that rest Fox doesn't necessarily
have uh we put this in our own
environment um it's kind of similar uh
but you can make for this collection
that we built we can actually do the
settings for the collection and if I
come in here I can set the auth up here
so I could do this basic auth here and
uh go grab my stuff and so just a
reminder in rest Fox uh when we did that
before we were in the environment of
twilio and I was able to grab the twilio
account Sid right
so let's go uh let's go back to our code
here and the twilio account set is the
username and the password let's go back
to that environment in rest Fox uh the
password is that awesome
there we go we'll paste that there
perfect so I'm going to click save on
this and so now this all media should
work so I'm going to go ahead I'm going
to do a send to this and there we go we
got it back and we can see uh um there's
a media list is the key here and again
it's an array of those and this is the
list of all of the media that's
available and so now look at this
collection so we have a collection of
accounts and here's a specific account
we have a collection that account has
messages uh that message has media and
that media has an entry a media entry
and that's it this is what we're looking
at right here so
something that's pretty cool the way
that this works is if I get this I can
get some metadata information about it
but if I get just a little bit of it if
I just go ahead and take this the way
that the way that twilio works and not
not all AP apis do this but if I do this
without the extension here I'll actually
get back the picture that I sent so I'm
going to do that I'm going to make a new
a new little request here so a new
request
and we're going to call this uh get the
pick right we're going to get that pick
that I sent because we don't still don't
know what that pick was what was it
let's go take a look so um so again at
the end of this uh
oops sorry at the at the end of this
there is no extension right so I got rid
of the dot Json extension and I'm going
to put at the front here https uh API
Dot twilio
.com
and uh
the interesting thing about this is this
pick is not authenticated if you do
authenticate you end up actually having
some problems so I'm going to tell this
request specifically to not inherit
value so I'm going to disable this so
that it's not authenticated so when I
click this if all goes well we should
see the pick that I submitted awesome
and we do uh cool so
um it's a little big it's a little big
of a pick
um that was sent here
um and uh we could take a look at some
stuff here we could look at the headers
that were sent
so we can see a couple things one of the
things that I think is really
interesting is when it says last
modified so uh the last modified date if
you have a request that has this on it
it means that you can use caching so you
can uh when you make the request you can
actually say if it's been modified since
this time I'll do that so I'm going to
do that I'm going to grab this let's
let's just take a look and see what that
does so I'm going to go to headers here
and I'm going to put a new header in
here
of if and you can see that there's
autocomplete so it's if modified since
so again this is the request that I am
making I'm making this request and I'm
going to say if it's been modified since
then uh give me it otherwise uh let me
know and so the way that it lets you
know
um is 304 not modified so that's a
status and you'll see that I got zero
bytes back so that is how caching Works
um and what you can do to send this
across so so this is really powerful
right I didn't need to set up all the
other things and it's kind of really a
quick little uh look at this I don't
actually need to do a collection I can
just do a new request outside of it and
I kind of explore through and see how
these things are working which ding ding
ding means we covered another part of a
restful API constraint scavenger hunt
using standard HTTP caching mechanisms
like last modified and e-tags a restful
API should support caching it's up to
you to maintain the cache on your client
and decorate your quests but this can
come in really handy to avoid making
unneeded requests and those are the the
postman-esque things I wanted you to see
they wanted you to be able to do that
without diving in necessarily to do all
of the postman Enterprise things that
you want to do but I think it's time I
think you should feel comfortable enough
that we can now look at Postman and see
what we've already learned there so I'm
gonna go uh here and I'm gonna just do a
quick
quick little Google search for Postman
and this is really nice you can do this
for whatever API you're working with and
since we're working with polio I'm going
to search for the postman twilio
collection
um so there's some docs on twilio about
it but if you look here there's this
twilio postman on the API Network so
this is important to know there's a lot
of uh things on this API Network where
they've built
uh apis for you to go and share so I'm
going to click this and now note I'm
inside of a web browser postman's done a
really gorgeous job of uh of letting you
run inside of your browser you also can
run it locally like we did with rest
walks um but I'm going to run this from
my browser so I'm going to go into this
messaging SMS
and you can see there's all sorts of
different things uh in here uh it's a
little bit hard to get to here but you
could change things put in your account
Sid and all sorts of things like we saw
look here's the double mustaches right
and here's the thing to send an SMS
um and it's
it's super cool
um it's it's neat right and so you've
seen this here's your authorization the
headers the body there's Collections and
uh what's cool is somebody's already
built these collections for you and
they're sharing your stuff this way
right so that's kind of that's kind of
nice so again there's path variables
right and the path variables coming up
here there's the the colon account Sid
that you saw uh from before here
somebody's using this as the start uh
the https API twilio.com and it's doing
a post right so it feels very similar so
you're familiar with this there's also a
bunch of other things over here that it
can do that could get a little bit
distracting and that's what I was trying
to kind of avoid uh um because I wanted
you to to get get familiar with it but
know that this exists
um one of the really cool things that
Postman does is if you click over here
on this far right over here there's this
little uh code it's like open close tag
this is really neat so
um we have curl right so we can see this
is how I would go ahead and do this and
this this feels familiar right this is
how what we actually did we did this
curl statement but check this out you
can do this in any programming language
so the trick here the trick to remember
is that any programming language that
can make an HTTP request like it has a
client built into it because these are
all standard the rest API right we're
following these constraints that have
been defined it can generate code for
you so here's node.js using a package
called axios so axios allows you to
fetch things so this is what it would
look like if you try to write that using
axios
um and if you look in here you come down
here here it is in PHP with with guzzle
I don't know what guzzle is I like that
though that's why I chose it um so you
can see that it's generating this code
for you and if I copy this and pasted it
into my PHP code or my python code or my
Java code it would just work and that's
really handy that is if the company
that's providing the API doesn't have a
helper library or an SDK a software
development kit which we haven't looked
at yet but we're about ready to
um twilio does have one of those but if
you were looking at one of these that
that didn't this is a great way to get
that code so again check out the API
Network this Postman API Network it's
cool I think you're ready now uh to use
this if you want to but also feel free
to use the other tools explore the apis
in the in a comfortable way wherever you
might be uh uh most comfortable with
because there's all sorts of really
fancy tools here on Postman and like I
said there are courses on how to take
full use of all of the things that are
available awesome job diving into all
those tools Postman is a super powerful
tool and it keeps getting better every
day there are so many features that we
didn't cover we barely even scratched
the surface there's an entire course out
there on it check the notes for a way to
see that
we saw how to organize our request
together into collections as well as
share common and secure values by using
variables we learned how to add
different values to requests both in
form values query strings and headers
and we also saw how to navigate through
various sub resources via clicking URLs
we even saw how to create actual
runnable code from your request while we
were in the twilio documentation you
might have noticed the code examples on
the screen on that page it's possible
the tab between various language
implementations and solutions many
products offer what is known as an SDK
or software development kit or helper
library that allows you to interact with
their product in your native language as
you can see it abstracts away the rest
API completely let's take a look at the
twilio helper library next
before that though just a quick reminder
to make sure that you check the notes on
this video there's a link to a
repository of built out collections that
are ready for you to use there are lots
of great apis to practice with
all the tools that we just looked at are
great for accessing and exploring apis
however when it comes time you're most
likely going to want to write some code
now as we saw in Postman you can
actually generate code all programming
languages have some sort of way of
making HTTP requests and as you know
HTTP requests are all we really need to
interact with rest apis so writing that
sort of code is totally fine but you'll
find that you'll end up writing a lot of
what is known as boilerplate code by
boilerplate I mean code that is
repetitive and almost always the same
just with a few tweaks many products and
services have created a solution to help
you avoid this problem they are often
called helper libraries or sdks software
development kits they'll be specific to
your programming language these
libraries help make your code more
concise and legible they usually also
provide additional documentation for
your editor which I find super handy
let's go check out some of these helper
libraries okay so let's take a look at
one of these helper libraries let's take
a look at the first one that's here so
so again I'm in the docs SMS create a
message resource I'm here under the curl
tab currently remember we did this we
went and we saw how to do this we passed
the from the body and the two we passed
in these environment variables that's
what this dollar is and this dollar
twilio auth token their environment
variables and it's also used here in the
URL uh so we had done that we had done
that with curl now one of the really
nice things
um about these helper libraries is they
look very similar but it's taken away
this whole notion so let's let's go here
I'm going to go to this node.js now
quick word of warning
if JavaScript is new to you
um there is some stuff here that might
be a little confusing and I want this to
just kind of kind of wash over you I
want you to do more feel what it feels
like as I explain it and don't be too
concerned with not exactly understanding
all of the things that can happen
especially if you're one of the folks
who has the hello world uh requirement
uh please don't feel like you need to
fully understand all this I will walk
through this code line by line and tell
you what it's doing and it will be
familiar to what we've been doing just
in a programming language that you might
not yet be familiar with so I'll take my
time and you take your time give
yourself some patience in fact I'd like
to suggest that if you are in the boat
where you have not written code like
this before that you watch me first and
then come back and do it later we're
going to take advantage of the fact that
we're in a video right you can take me
right back to right right here and take
me back to right here and we can get
started so one of the things that I love
about twilio's documentation is that you
can just copy it and it should work so
this is what was happening when we
created something here right so we
created a message so this is uh you get
this authenticated client right we know
what that is we authenticate with our
client uh with our with our account Sid
and our auth token like we've been doing
and then we're going to do this messages
a client so client dot messages there's
our
restclient.messages DOT create and we're
going to pass in the from the body and
the two and it's got all the information
that we know and then there's doing some
of this JavaScript stuff so then we're
going to get a promise back and then
we're going to get access to the message
and this console log is going to print
out to the screen uh I don't think we
should send a message why don't we look
at the messages that we've done let's
let's do that so I'm going to go to that
example so I'm going to choose I don't
hear this list all messages awesome so
we'll take a look at all of the messages
that are in the account now what I can
do is I can just copy this so I'm going
to copy this and I'm going to run it on
my local machine now I'm just exploring
and this probably happens as you're
looking at apis so so typically I have a
folder on my computer called scratch and
if you want to make one you do maker
scratch this is going to put this
wherever you want to and then you get
into that directory um if you're doing
this in a terminal on Windows there are
some instructions in the notes on how to
do exactly that so now I've got this
directory named scratch now I told you
before I was using visual studio code
which I hope that you have installed and
so I'm going to do code Dot and if this
doesn't work for you there are
instructions on how to get this
installed properly on your machine what
it should do is pop open my visual
studio code directly in that directory
so I'm in this directory here and I'm
going to make a new file here I'm going
to call it
explorer.js this is typically what I do
so I'm going to come in here and I'm
going to paste that code awesome so now
I have this code here and the code is on
my local machine
um which is awesome so now now I'm going
to try to make this code run now one
thing that I know for sure that I need
to do is I need to download the helper
Library
um so if I wanted to go here I could go
to this node install I happen to know
how to do that so I'm going to go up
here under terminal and then we do new
terminal and in Visual Studio code this
is really nice my terminal can actually
run the same terminal that I used to
open it is running down here in the
bottom and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use a package manager to
install
um the twilio
helper Library so I'm going to say npm
install twilio so npm is node package
manager
and if you do not have this if this does
not work check the notes because it
means that node is probably not
installed on your computer and if notice
not installed on your computer there's a
great walkthrough in the notes on how to
get node installed so I now have uh
twilio helper Library installed which
means this require twilio statement here
is requiring that Library
remember in rest Fox how there was an
environment and we stored the account
Sid and the auth token we can do the
same thing on our local machine we can
set up a little environment here and
actually if we go ahead and we click
this uh twilio secure there's some great
examples in here and how you could do
that so one of the things that this
suggests doing um you can see it's for
mac and Linux and different different
shells have do different things
um if you run this in your command line
you can set your environment variables
and then when you run node it will work
I'm going to do I'm going to do this one
so I'm going to copy copy this here
and uh I am going to
just paste this we'll paste this I'll
show you show you what it does so uh I I
it's it's saying we want to export my
account Sid and my auth token which is
we're very familiar with these days so
uh we're gonna we're gonna do that let's
let's do this real quick
so
I'm gonna pop in my account token there
I'm gonna go back over uh to my console
scroll down and grab my account here and
then I'm going to paste that
and I am going to go and grab my auth
token and I am going uh to base that so
again I got to that oops
accidentally pasted my auth token in the
wrong line there so I know that it
started with a four
and I'm going to paste it down here
where it says your auth token so
basically what this is doing is this is
writing a new file that will have this
information I'll show you that here in a
second so there's there's my um it's
going to write these two lines I'll show
you I'll show you what that looks like
so I'm gonna it's gonna create a new
file called twilio imp and it's going to
append that that's what this Double Dash
Dash Twitter and then I was going to
source that which means uh put run that
environment variable so uh if all is
working well now if I say uh Echo and I
can do twilio account
Sid
we can see that I have that available
and that created this file here called
twilio INF and you can see there is my
account set in my token which is nice
because now this code uh works it should
be working and using this and in fact if
all is going right so I've I've got node
installed I ins I installed the helper
Library
um I put my account Sid
from the console into this twilio imp
and then I did this final command here
the source twilio imv which will run
that file and put those uh variables
into my environment variables uh and as
I showed you that they were working so
so let's go ahead and let's do node
Explorer so what's going to happen let's
take a look really quick I'll show you
let's see let's make sure we got it
working cool we did so so let's walk the
code really quick so this is pasted
straight from the uh straight from those
docs so we're getting a client back from
this required twilio this is a twilio
library and when you get the twilio
library if you pass it in account Sid
and an auth token it'll automatically
create a brand new rest client for you
right so this is a client that you're
able to use to hit the rest API at
twilio and because it knows who you are
it's able to access stuff on your behalf
so very similar to what we're doing with
the curl but this client we can use this
multiple times it will always be
authenticated so we're saying of all of
the messages we want to list them all
right so we want to get a list of all of
the messages actually not all of them
only 20 of those
um so let's go ahead I'm going to just
we know that we haven't sent 20. I'm
going to get rid of this so you can kind
of just see this other style here so
we're going to say of those uh we're
gonna do this list and then I'm going to
bring this back a little bit here so you
can kind of see
let's change the structure of this a
little bit so we'll say client
messages and then we're going to do a
list on those now the way that the way
that this works is
um this is asynchronous
so JavaScript is asynchronous and if
JavaScript is new to you you probably
haven't encountered Its asynchronous
Behavior what we're going to go over
here might very well be overwhelming but
it'll make sense someday if you stick
with it I promise
now I've added notes but really please
please please please do not let this
stress you out I just want this to go
over
your mind about what's Happening Here
and it's important to understand because
our client here this late these list
methods are asynchronous that which
means that it's going to go and run off
and do some things and then it's going
to come back when that comes back it's
going to run this code so this is how a
promise works so it's it's going to say
then after you go and make that request
then give me the messages and just so
you what's what's kind of strange about
that is if you're probably used to code
working like this so I'm going to write
out to the screen that's this console
log I'm going to say starting
starting program
and we should see that line print now
you might think that this is going to
print it's going to run this and then go
but if you I'll show you here if I do
this console log and I say Gathering
message log
um what what you'll see is it's going to
say this this line is going to start but
immediately it's going to go to the next
line so let's do that let's run that one
more time
I didn't save it so of course it won't
do anything so you can see this little
dot here in Visual Studio it didn't save
so I'm going to save that run that one
more time here we go
and you'll see right away it's a
starting program Gathering message log
so it it ran this but then it went down
to here so it did not wait because this
is asynchronous what's Happening Here is
asynchronous and what's happening is
client message list returns a promise
now it's a promise that in the future
there will be a value and that value is
messages and so the way that you write
that code is this then Waits it defines
a function here and as soon as this is
done it will run this function as soon
as they come back it will run the
function so that's what happened right
so it came it started it then ran the
function
and when I say function you might not
have seen this before but in JavaScript
you can make a function I'm going to put
parentheses here so it's a little bit
more clear these are the parameters for
the function and this fat arrow is
saying this is what happens when the
function runs this like little they call
it the fat Arrow it's kind of cute right
so it's an equal sign and then a greater
than it's a it's called a fat arrow and
it's a way of quickly defining a
function and so you can see here there's
another one here that's doing it as well
so it could be a little bit uh um Messy
as you're looking at you see how all
these parens that we're looking at it's
kind of kind of hard to understand and
read if this is your first time looking
at that I totally feel for you
and so this messages that comes through
here is an array so so what was very
nice is it came across this messages
list this is an array it was a
JavaScript array by itself they have
this method called for each on it and it
will let you Loop through each of the
values that are in an array
um and you'll notice that the object
that was inside of that array has some
properties so what happened was the
client went and made the request made
the HTTP request it got back that Json
that we saw let me let me just go show
you one more time uh let's make sure
that we're looking at the right thing
here so so we we we this is the same
code that we just saw this Json was
returned right this Json is return but
what the client did for us was it
inflated these into messages right so
these are this is this this is a string
of things and it came back Json but I'm
able to actually work with each of these
messages as if they're an object
so let's look look at that again so uh
list returned this object this array of
messages and each one of those in that
array I'm able to use an array method
for each and this message is an actual
object that has a property called Sid so
again if that is all new JavaScript
terms to you don't worry too much about
it basically we went and got the
messages and we showed the messages that
we got that's what this is saying
one of the things that I want you to be
careful of as you're looking at promises
and you might see this sometimes as you
work with apis because oftentimes apis
that you hit are going to be
asynchronous like this you might see
that you need to be able to you might
run into an error and what's good what
might happen is it might get swallowed
in fact let me cause one to happen so
here it's supposed to say auth token I'm
just going to put in uh
um my luggage the password to my luggage
one two three four five six so that is
not my account said that is going in
there so I have the wrong account said
so I'm gonna say that hey this is the
client this is what how I want you to
authenticate and it's going to go to try
to make this and it's going to fail
let's see what happens when it fails
well I didn't save it so let's save it
again boy that's a lesson that I'm
really hit in the home you gotta make
sure you save your file or the code
doesn't run so let's do it again
um and you'll notice that I didn't get
any error at all and that can be
confusing that that is something that is
very strange because obviously something
wrong happened I didn't get any of the
messages back but it doesn't look like I
did I had any problems so what's
happening because this is running
asynchronously this then never runs
right we never get a chance to run this
because this list method method didn't
actually uh finish working so one of the
things you always want to make sure that
you do is to every promise you can catch
and you can catch an error and I'm going
to make a fat Arrow because I'm going to
have a function happen here that says
console.error err okay so now I'm going
to print that out I'm going to print out
the error let's run that again let's see
what happens ah now we see the error and
you'll see that sometimes uh this is uh
what comes back is there is an
authentication error right and we got a
very specific error on this 2003 and it
will help us kind of look at what's
happening oh here great this is right my
off token is wrong the wrong combination
of accounts that off token exactly that
is what has happened um so cool use of
uh things there I'm going to put this
back so that we have uh things working
uh so this was auth token and I can
still leave my error in there I'm not
going to hit an error so it's not going
to happen so a promise has a then and
also has a catch right so uh let's do
that so I'm gonna run that one more time
and save it wow y'all I gotta get better
at saving here we go there we go so now
we're back to working again awesome
all right I'm going to show you a little
bit of a different way that JavaScript
can work asynchronously that you might
also see and this is really syntactical
sugar it's called async a weight and if
you just uh wait a bit it will all sink
in I promise that's a there's three
jokes in that one that was a that was a
hat trick of a joke all right so here we
go so
um the way that it works the way that
this works is you can say that if a
function is going to be asynchronous and
we want this to run
um uh asynchronously so I was thinking
we're getting ready to start using our
number in an application and to get
there we need to clean it up we have a
bunch of weird messages in there that
aren't going to be relevant to the
messages that we have so I'm going to
make a a new function and I'm going to
call it delete all messages okay and
when you define a function you can kind
of put the this is the parameters that
it takes we're not going to say that
there are no parameters and then I'm
going to run this function
so
um well this is an asynchronous function
I can actually make it look more uh like
it is in line so it can kind of run the
way that we want it to so I'm going to
say const messages
equals
a weight so now I have because the
function itself is asynchronous because
I've used this here I can use this
keyword await and I'm going to say
client
Dot
messages dot list
and so now I think this is a little bit
more clear right so this is basically
doing the same thing right these
messages are the same messages that were
coming into this function but now it's
out on this side so I have this variable
that's called messages so um and that's
an array right and then and I could do I
could do this exact same thing here and
I could list that uh the same way but
let's let's go a little bit farther so
I'm going to say for each of the
messages for each message that is of the
messages array
so these are those uh inflated messages
that we saw uh one of the cool things
um that you're able to do with the
client is the the the object that's
returned back has actually has some
properties on them and one of those
properties that it has is called delete
uh before we do that I'm gonna make sure
that let's do a warning uh here real
quick so I'm going to say
console.orn we're gonna say would have
deleted I'm actually going to use if you
use these back ticks this is kind of a
neat trick you can use this backtick to
do string interpolation so we'll say I
would have deleted message dot Sid so
again that's the string identifier of
that so I would have deleted message dot
said so and we will close that function
out all right and now I'm going to call
that function
and this you know of course that's how
we we call it and this is would actually
be a promise this would be a very
similar so we could do this we could do
within uh hold in fact let's do it we'll
say then and uh if you wanted to call uh
make a function that has no parameters
because I'm not returning anything right
I'm not returning anything from that
function I'm just going to say
console.log and I'm going to write done
and I will put all of these this code
into the note so you uh can also copy
and paste it if you want to and I'm
going to do the same thing that I did
before catch the error and I'll do will
do console.error and now if you do the
console is you know of course what's
running when the program runs it's
running out to the screen and there's
different levels that you can do and
error is one of those and if I just pass
the error that happened there so
um I'm going to warn that we're gonna
would have deleted the message but let's
let's take a look at what happens so I'm
going to get rid I'm going to keep the
starting program here right so we're
going to do a starting program
and then it's going to do delete all
messages it's going to call that and
then when it's all done it will say done
I'm going to get rid of what we had here
okay so we have delete all messages it's
going to go and it's going to get a list
of all the messages it's going to Loop
through each one of those messages and
uh when it is done it's right now we're
going to warn that it's uh would have
deleted it and this is uh what we're
eventually going to do because there's a
function that's available to it all
right so I'm going to save that I'm
going to run it let's see what happens
okay so it would have deleted some of
our SIDS and again this is the mm this
is the the mm means as it was the MMS
which is the one with the picture and
the rest of the estims that we have so I
think I am ready to do this I hope that
you are ready to do this as well
um again this code uh should you want it
is available in uh their repo because
you want to run this because you want to
delete these messages
um so let's let's I'm going to say setup
would have deleted I'm going to say
deleting and then uh
here we go I'm going to save that I'm
going to run it and so so message the
message object that's coming back from
this client is really has enough
information to make another API call to
delete itself right because
um because the object itself knows how
to do that the library has made an
object that is smart enough to be able
to call delete on it and it feels like
um it's just working that way but it's
really making a rest API call to make a
delete request it's pretty cool right
here we go
a message dot delete is not a function
uh what I meant was actually remove so
the function name is remove on the
message so here we go so
um and you saw that there was an error
right that was the error that just
happened the good thing I put that catch
in there otherwise we would have thought
it worked so here we go so node explore
remove and said deleting deleting
deleting we deleted all of those
um so remove is the name of the function
that's there but it is doing a delete
making a delete call cool so we have now
cleaned out and if we try to run it
again you'll see that there's no
messages left for it to delete
awesome now if you have just watched
that and we're very confused let's walk
this last bit and then I want you to
rewind it one more time so I've made a
function that is asynchronous and that
function is called delete all messages
and because it's asynchronous I'm able
to use this await which will return this
this client.messages.list returns a
promise okay but a promise of the future
but because it's being awaited it's
going to return it right here in line
then I'm going to Loop through each of
those messages and because that message
came back from the API and an object was
created thanks to our helper Library
here I have a I have a method on that
message called remove and it will
actually go and do the next level the
next level of delete there for me so
it's it's really nice this object feels
like it would uh
feel like if you were writing JavaScript
code it would feel this way but behind
the scenes we know that it's doing this
API calls and the client library has
abstracted all of that away from us uh
and if now if you go and you take a look
let's go back really quick let's take a
look there's other helper libraries so
if python happens to be your your
language there's how you do it so it's
client.messages.list and for record and
messages and you print the record Sid
and you can see that the code looks a
little bit different and all the
languages that you go through but it's
also kind of similar and so that's
really nice about the standardness of a
rest API is that the helper library is
producing code that feels the same in
each way because the library is kind of
the same and you'll you'll find that as
you use other apis and they have helper
libraries they will they will mimic the
way that the rest API looks so I
realized that was a lot I don't want you
to get hung up if you feel like you
can't completely understand what that is
uh in the next unit what we're going to
do is we're going to go into more deep
things and I know you can do this uh so
so there this code is there and also if
you feel like you want me to go back and
explain that again please please please
please please pause me slow me down let
me walk through those different things
but don't feel like you need to be able
to read this I want you to just
conceptually understand that you're
using a helper Library that's
abstracting away all of the HTTP API
things that we were doing with curl and
we were doing with rest Fox this is just
doing it in code and it's doing it for
you a lot of the magic is gone
uh and hidden and tucked away and it
just feels like you're actually working
with these objects That's The Power of
this abstraction awesome did you see how
the helper libraries are all similar yet
match the development workflow and style
of each language this is one of the
benefits of helper libraries in general
they abstract away the HTTP client
connection and the boilerplate necessary
to make rest API calls they also behave
as you expect them to behave it feels
natural
the way that we were able to delete from
the resource itself helps to unlock
another rest API constraint scavenger
hunt item and that one is uniform design
now this constraint has four subsections
one of which we just discussed resource
manipulation through representations
because enough information was included
in the response it was clear for us how
we could modify and delete the resource
another subsection in here is resource
identification and requests that's the
Uris that are included and we've seen
that but because the Uris are included
we know how to get and manipulate
specific resources uniform use of the
HTTP verbs is pretty powerful we just
wrote some scripts that make use of
helper libraries these libraries are
super handy for automation-based tasks
or batch scripting which is like making
a whole bunch of calls at once now while
we're talking about this we should cover
another common tool for talking to
external apis and that one is CLI
command line interface there it is again
command line interfaces can be used to
make API calls from an executable on
your machine more and more these are
showing up for tools that require
authentication and do a bunch of
different services this concept is
popular amongst Cloud providers where
setting something up needs to be done
quickly from the command line check the
notes for more another common place
where you'll use helper libraries is
from within applications that you're
building
let's get to the final unit of this
course and Implement an external API
into an existing web application you've
got this oh we're here I love this part
the building part we're going to build a
web application that shows off a set of
User submitted photos for a specific
prompt but here's where our app is going
to stick out from all the rest we're
going to let our users submit their
photos and captions via a text message
what this will enable us to do is put up
signs and billboards and physical spaces
it says text a photo to this number and
then our site will gather those on a web
page and display them now you're
probably wondering two things right now
the first one is probably wait what are
those photos they're going to be texting
and that's a great question we're going
to be building this application so it
can be dynamic so you can Define
whatever you want like text me a photo
of your dog
send us a photo of the view out your
windows snap me a pic of the best
impersonation of me I I don't know
anything along those lines now secondly
you're probably wondering wait a second
you said I didn't need to know how to
code if you already know how to make a
website this part might not phase you
but if building a website is outside of
your Learning Journey thus far no sweat
I've got it set up and we're going to
take our time we're going to focus on
making things work using this API all
right let's do this okay so I have a
template here in the notes uh in the uh
unit 3 video one we have this index.html
which is our web application
um if you come in here you can scroll
you can kind of see things here we've
the app is called pickle where you get a
pick your picks Peter picked a pickle
pickle that sort of fun joke there and
then we're gonna click this RAW button
right here we're gonna get a hold of
this Raw
and I am going to highlight everything
and use the magical developer
command C copy and then I'm going to
come over to back to my scratch on my
visual studio code I'm going to make a
new file I'm going to call that
index.html hypertext markup language
right and I'm going to paste that right
here so now I have that code locally on
my machine if you are a git user you
could definitely check this out and have
your own version of this if you wanted
to but that's a good way to get this
here locally because we're just going to
explore around here just for a little
bit
let's take a look at this file as it
exists this is this is something that
might happen to you as a developer who
knows now about apis they might say hey
I've got this template and I would love
for you to be able to set it up to make
the the API work so the first thing to
do if you want to look at an index file
locally on your computer you could set
up a web server I've made it so we don't
need to have a web server so we can just
go ahead I'm going to go to my terminal
I'm going to do a new terminal here
I'm going to open that up and I'm just
going to say open index.html now what
that's going to do
um uh in my Mac is going to open this up
for Windows take a look and see how to
do this exactly but what this will do it
will update my uh my pickle here so so
you can see this is this user scratch
and then you know my whatever it is it's
in my my directory there and uh this is
what's happening there's some some nice
kitty photos there I'll show you how
that's working and if you uh click into
one of them you get a nice little
Gallery here and you can switch between
the different kitties and you can see
the text that the user uh submitted
that's kind of where we're going with
this that's what we're planning on doing
very nice setup a simple one little
pager application uh because I'm using
some apis to to be able to do that here
locally I'm using uh remember apis not
not web apis but I'm using a view as the
framework that I'm using I'm using a
framework called View and it has an API
and I'm also using this silent box which
is allowing us to do that pop-up it also
has an API let's take a little bit of a
look here so I'm going to move I'm going
to move a little bit slow through this
um just so in case this is your first
time seeing something like this
I've got some setup here in this head
tag you can see this HTML this is the
head tag there's some setup so I'm using
View and I'm also using silent box and
I've got some very minimal styling
um it's not my my forte uh and
oftentimes you're given a template like
this so you're given hey here's a
working thing I would love for you to
get some apis in there
um so the the body of the app has this
you'll see notice this little mustache
mustache and it says call to action so
um in view this is part of their API is
if you use this for a template it will
be replaced with something from The View
object's data so you can see here
there's this call to action and that's
what this is and this is why I can
change this and make this say whatever I
wanted to say it would be here so
whatever we decide to do with our apps
whatever kind of picks that we're trying
to collect that would be where we would
change that and then you also see here
there's this silent box and it's doing a
gallery and the way that that works is
we pass in this gallery from again from
this view objects Gallery you don't
necessarily need to worry too much about
this but I wanted to show you on that
there is this is how view works it's a
front-end framework and it provides an
API where if I give it a function called
data and whatever's in here will get
returned to it and then there's some
more I can Define some methods on The
View object one of those methods that
I've defined is called load images
part of the API that view creates is
there is a lifecycle method called
mounted which means that when the
application is ready and it has been
mounted onto your HTML through the
JavaScript it will call this function so
it's going to call this load images
function
and this load images function you'll
notice it's an async uh image and I've
got some to-do's in here this is some
place where you might be communicating
back and forth with people as you're
working uh together on a project so use
the messaging API to use uh submitted
photos and also create a web-based API
that matches this expected response so
that's what we're going to do over the
next couple of videos here so what we
see in the start here is there's this
gallery and it is an array and it's got
um some stuff from this there's a
website called Place kitten that I used
here so you can get different versions
of kitties here and there's a
description and there's an ALT tag which
is important because uh for for
accessibility reasons it this is what it
will say on the picture so uh that is
what is happening to be able to make
that work
um so we we now have our app here uh
locally and we can change things so um
one of the things one of the photos
um that I want to do uh I love to get
photos of burritos from around town so
I'm going to change this I'm gonna say
submit me a photo of your uh burritos
and I'm Gonna Save that file so see it's
not saved I'm going to save it when I go
back to my file there when I refresh it
you can see that it says burritos what
are you going to want to gather why
don't you go ahead and change that uh
change that to whatever it is that
you're wanting to gather as we build
this project through and of course you
know you see that you can change that
however so make sure that it's
downloaded and make sure that you can
change that you can change this file and
it opens uh locally on your machine cool
and so now we have a little smattering
of apis here already so we have a web we
have HTML working here we have this View
and this view API has a very specific
API that's doing this mounted uh here
but remember it is actually an API and
we're going to use a web-based API to be
able to to get this information and
we're going to do that here in just a
bit now that we got our file all working
let's deploy it and by that I mean let's
get it up on the public internet so
everyone can see it that is of course
after you take a quick break
[Music]
we're gonna get our web page up on the
Internet so others can see it and this
has gotten much easier as time has
progressed you used to have to set up a
server like a physical computer buy a
domain name and configure it to point to
your machine you have to figure out
where to host like to where to locate
your server so that it was always on and
arguably the hardest part after it was
live you used to have to watch over it
in case too many people came to it you
didn't want to get overloaded you wanted
it to scale up and be able to handle the
traffic
those servers are still around but these
days you don't really need to worry
about them too much now I'm sure that
you've heard the term the cloud and the
colloquium the cloud is just other
people's computers well let's talk a bit
about serverless serverless is just
other people's servers it removes all
those previous things that we had to
worry about and it offloads your
concerns
I can tell by the look on your face that
it's probably better if I just show you
let's get this application hosted
so we're going to have twilio host our
code for us and that is to say we are
going to have twilio BR web server that
will be used to serve our HTML our
project will be serverless now the way
you do that is by using twilio's
serverless environment which is here
under functions and Assets Now if you
don't have that here if you click
explore products
and you come to developer tools and you
come over to functions and assets you
can click this little pin icon and that
will make it show up here
so I am going to create a new service so
I'm going to go functions and assets
services and I'm going to say create
service it could be whatever you want
I'm going to call it pickle like pick
your picks with pickle
Peter
Services allow us to group our functions
and assets together for our application
so I'm going to click next and what's
going to happen is we're going to open
up to a very nice IDE that will allow us
to edit our code now a friendly reminder
if you're having a hard time following
along because my screen looks different
than yours
you are using a new and improved
experience so check the notes for what
might be different
now traditionally these Services here
are used to power twilio-based
applications remember how I said you
could respond programmatically to an
incoming message well functions are a
great way to do just that in fact our
current number has a default response
and we might as well fix it while we're
here but before we do that let's get our
HTML code up and running so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to grab code
from my local machine and if you want to
you can just grab it from GitHub check
the notes for more on that but I'm going
to go add I'm going to choose upload
file I'm going to find my file my
index.html and I'm going to choose open
now what we're uploading we'd like the
world to be able to see it so I'm going
to choose public and then I'm going to
choose upload
so now this file's over here you'll
notice this little Green Dot and this
means that it is not yet deployed and
that is it's not yet available on the
internet in this current state so let's
do that I'm going to do that by clicking
this deploy all button down here
and now we see that it's green and I'm
going to go ahead and choose copy URL
and I'm going to open up a new tab with
that there and we will see that our site
is live except it says burritos and
these are kittens but we're getting
there so uh it's working it's up it's on
the internet I could share this with
people
the pickle site is up and running on
twilio's servers one of the things that
I used to have to worry about was scale
like what if I got a whole bunch of
requests to this site would it fall over
what the serverless solution is doing is
allowing me to not need to worry about
any of that anymore twilio is handling
all those concerns for me which is great
because now I can focus on what I was
building which by the way we need to
handle that reply programmatically right
so the way that twilio does things is
with web hooks now if you haven't
encountered web hooks before I have an
entire course on them that I link to in
the notes
web hooks are sometimes called a reverse
API that is instead of you calling the
API the API calls you so let's configure
our number to make use of the right web
hook so I'm going to go back to my
number uh over here if I look under
phone numbers and I do manage I'm going
to hold down uh command or control and
click active numbers I'll open up a new
tab nice little hack to keep your screen
open here so I've got my numbers here
and if I come in here to configure it
what happens is I'm going to scroll down
so here's the voice section and then
here's the messaging section and it says
when a message comes in to this web hook
and it sends to this
URL here it does a post to this URL here
so the way that twilio makes use of web
hooks can be thought of like this you
know when I hit this URL right this URL
in my browser
my browser doesn't care about what's
happening at that end point it could
have been anything any web server like
Express Django a Java server it doesn't
matter what matters is that what was
returned from my server was HTML or
hypertext markup language my server
responds with HTML and my browser
renders the page now the same is true
with twilio someone is going to text our
twilio number and twilio is going to
send a request to an endpoint in this
case this endpoint here it doesn't
matter what is happening on the other
side as long as it returns twiml or
twilio markup language they look very
similar HTML and twiml
twilio will be able to render your
application so we could set up a new web
server to host this application that
returns twiml or
we could just use a twilio function and
like I said earlier that is what these
are commonly used for so let's let's pop
back to our service
so I'm going to come here I'm going to
add a new function and I'm going to name
this function incoming message that's
what we're going to do we're going to
handle an incoming message
and there is some very nice default
boilerplate that is commented that comes
through so boilerplate is code that's
provided that's usually the most common
thing that you're going to be doing and
in this case it is it's boilerplate for
how to respond to an incoming phone call
it's kind of like the hello world of uh
voice applications but
we're going to be building a messaging
application so we'll need to tweak this
just a bit now I've put this code I'm
about to show you into the notes so I
don't want you to feel like you have to
type this all out or even fully
understand every line I will step you
through it
first though let me walk you through
this function just a bit so twilio
functions all export a thing called a
Handler
and that Handler takes a function that
takes some parameters context events and
callback
context here is an object that holds
information about the function that's
running like it knows the domain it
knows the name of the function and the
event here you can kind of think of this
like a web request in most Frameworks
and if you haven't seen a framework
before this is kind of the way that
information is passed into your web
application ah so so this is the event
will hold everything about the text
message that was incoming because that's
what twilio does twilio is going to pass
that information through here and for
instance that message will have the two
it'll have from and body and again
because when the text message comes in
we are going to point our phone number
to this function so twilio will post the
information here it will call our
function instead of us writing code that
checks if a new message was added over
and over again twilio is going to call
us the API is going to call us via a web
hook web hooks are pretty cool uh check
the notes and then finally there's this
callback uh object here which is how we
send information out of the function
it's actually a function so we have this
callback this is the errors that might
have happened and then this is what gets
returned and here's that twiml twilio
markup language
so I'm going to get rid of a couple of
these lines here these are sort of demo
lines I'm going to get rid of that
and I want you to be able to see what's
coming into the message so I'm going to
start up here I'm going to do a
console.log and what what this does is
when the function runs uh if we want to
we can see the message that will show up
down here so uh let's say that we got an
incoming message
and uh it was
incoming message and we'll just do a
colon and then I'm gonna use this dollar
this style of string interpolation so I
have the event object and on it there is
a property called body with a capital B
so that's being passed in there so uh
when the function runs we will see that
the message came in because twilio is
going to pass that message and we'll see
it there and we're just going to say
thanks when somebody sends Us in so we
don't really need to do anything with
this message but you might want to
filter it or handle things differently
based on what they said in the message
and you totally could do that but you'd
probably also want to check the photo
that came in and was actually a burrito
or something not in a props you could do
that and there are apis for that but
that's a little out of scope so instead
of a voice response we're actually going
to return a messaging response and
there's a little helper Library here
right so a little helper library for
twiml uh and it has this twiml object
and uh before it was doing say which is
text to speech so if you you wired this
up it would uh say Hello World in like a
computer even actually pretty good
sounding voice these days but I'm going
to change this to be a message because
that's what we want to return we want to
turn a message and we want to say uh
thanks
for your
submission right we want to want to
thank them there we can also send any
sort of emoji here let's see maybe a
camera that sounds yeah that's nice
thanks for your submission
and so what's happening here is this
object it's a fluid API it means that it
doesn't return anything you kind of
tweak it and and it builds as things go
uh on it so you'll notice that this
isn't returning anything I'm modifying
this object and then uh when I send it
out at the end that's how how it goes
out so let me let's just let me show you
what that object looks like so again
I'll do one of these con console.log
and use the back tick and we'll say
twiml so twilio markup language was uh
twiddle and you'll see that it looks a
lot like HTML uh there are some rules to
it but we don't need to learn them all
right now
so I'm going to save this
and uh just like before you'll notice
that this is gray it hasn't been
deployed so I'm going to click deploy
all and while that's building I'm going
to head back to my phone number page and
I'm going to refresh it
so on my phone number page I need to
change my message down here it says when
a when a message comes in we want it to
be a function that is in the pickle
service that's done in the UI and we
want to choose incoming message which it
hasn't finished deploying yet just
finished deploying one more time let me
refresh that page so that shows up for
us
uh we're going to go to when a message
comes in it's going to be a function and
it's on the pickle service for this UI
and we want to do incoming message and
if we do save
all right so we should be all wired up
I'm going to click uh clear logs here
and I'm going to turn uh live logs on
you can see that this says live logs on
when it's ready I'm going to clear the
logs one more time and what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to send a message in
and we should see this we should see
what what I send in and we should see
the twiml that was sent back and I
should get a response back so let me let
me send that message here let me send
this text
all right so oh let's check out this I
have look at this beautiful picture of a
burrito I love when burritos can stand
up by themselves and this is an awesome
one uh I'm gonna send us in uh so check
out this beautiful burrito little Emoji
I'm gonna send that through and we
should see here in the live Vlogs we
should see the message come through
there we go so look at this beautiful
burrito
um and this is the twiml that was
generated so you can see it's like tag
based so there's a response and there's
a closing response and there's an
opening message and a closing message
thanks for your submission I don't want
you to feel like you need to learn twiml
uh you could do that later uh if you
need to uh but but this uh works so I
got my message back no remember since we
are in trial mode if somebody else sends
in a message to your phone number
they're only going to get a message back
if they're a verified sender so that is
a limit of the trial API that we're
using currently now most apis have
limits there's only so many calls you
can make
there's you can only send to verified
numbers there's just different sort of
limits and that's what we're working
with here right now the limit is that
you can only send to verified numbers uh
they can still submit they just won't
get this thanks for your submission so
your phone number should so when you
submit from your phone number you should
get it just like I did all right so
we're looking good we have our site
hosted and we're handling submissions by
thanking them
let's get to some more cooking now if
you're interested in learning more about
applications like this over the phone
check out the notes for more resources I
have an entire course on this if this
piqued your interest but for now let's
get back to our API
now with our ability to host our own
application we can focus on designing
our own API now the great news is that
twilio functions makes it really
straightforward to return Json remember
that's JavaScript object notation the
lingua Franca of the web
let's design our web-based API to return
the expected format and we can make use
of twilio's message Api to get a hold of
all the messages that we received do you
see what I did there get get it
all right I'm gonna get out of here okay
I can't stop all right let's do this
okay so we're gonna actually write an
API and we already have a spec or a
specification right we need to provide
for the specific plugin this silent box
has this Gallery plug-in and it has a
specific API that it defines and that
API looks like this right so remember
that we're setting this gallery and
we're setting an array we're setting
this information here so I think we
should start by creating an endpoint
that returns exactly what we have here
we should return an endpoint that does
this that returns this and then we'll
move forward from there this is what I
do when I find myself in a situation
when I'm working on a project with a
team of people I take what they expect
in a template and I return it from an
API this way they can keep working and I
can keep working too so let's do that
I'm going to create a new function so
I'm going to choose add add function and
I can name this whatever I want and I
suppose we should be clear right we're
gonna make an API we're actually going
to make one so slash API and then I
suppose we should probably say what it's
going to be so we'll do a PIX API here
right
and I'm going to press enter and that
will get me my boilerplate code uh of
which I am going to get rid of
everything so uh thank you for the help
we're not actually returning twiml this
time we're actually going to return an
object and uh what I'll do is I'll copy
the hard-coded array from this index
file here
I'll come in here and I'll copy this
hard code now hard-coded means uh it is
just like in the code this way right
there's no way that this is going to be
dynamic I'm going to change that uh here
I'm going to paste that in here I'm
going to name it the same thing so I'm
going to create a new variable called
gallery
and I am going to just paste that
hard-coded code there there we go and
then I'm going to call this uh gallery
so again I have an array that's what
this this bracket here is this array of
these objects that's what these objects
are these these uh mustaches they open
up and the objects have these properties
here
and these are representing the picks
that uh that plug-in requires and now
I'm going to use this callback function
to return that Gallery array one really
nice thing about this twilio function is
that if I pass it an object like I did
it'll automatically return Json to
anybody who requests the URL so let's do
that so I'm going to go ahead I'm going
to save this and I'm going to deploy it
now one thing to note by default it was
actually protected that's what this
little key lock thing means here so I'm
going to click this then I'm going to
change this to be public because we
actually want anybody to be able to see
it not just twilio
um so this is this is what we're going
to do I'm going to change this to be
public and then I'm going to choose
deploy all and you'll see that it's gray
and when it's ready it will turn green
for us
um and so I'm going to go ahead I'm
going to copy this URL so I have this
URL ready and when it's green when this
goes uh to be deployed so it's still
deploying you can see it's deploying and
you'll know down here
um when it'll say build completed and
it'll say deployed so it's deployed so
copy that URL I am going to go hit that
URL and let's see what we get back
awesome we got it so we got the kitty
descriptions and blow this up a little
bit here this is this is Json it
automatically built this for us right I
put the it's in the right format which
is very nice in fact we could probably
take this and why don't we we'll go over
to the ThunderClan client and take a
look at what's going on over there so
I'm going to come back to my thunder
clients I'm going to make a new request
and I'm going to hit I'm going to do a
get to this this API that we just built
and check it out it comes back it comes
back with 200 okay and here's the the
stuff that's coming back there's even
some headers in here uh oh sorry some
some if we look at the response we can
look at the response headers over here
and we can see uh that the content type
was set to application Json uh twilly
always sends back to the shenanigans
none which I love
so now what we could do is we can give
this URL to the team that's working on
making the front end you know that that
View application they could wire it up
they could take this and as long as we
match the same format and what we return
that is as long as our API maintains the
same contract
everything should just work
so
that's pretty awesome right so let's
move on to the next part I'm going to
comment out uh this bit so let's let's
go ahead let's give it a uh we're gonna
go ahead and make this an empty array
right so that's how you make an empty
array and I'm going to comment this out
so that we have it so that we can kind
of look at what the format is as we
build stuff here so I'm going to comment
that out and in fact I don't think I
need uh the second one I'll just get
that first one there give us some space
there awesome
so now
let's use the text messages that were
sent in our incoming messages so
we're going to write some JavaScript
code now if you aren't quite fluent yet
in JavaScript remember that is okay and
we've all been there and we all all of
us I guarantee you everybody watching
this understands that what you're going
through can be challenging it's a new
language
I want you to try a follow along
conceptually and I want you to take your
time and I want you to take advantage of
being in a video based course this code
that we are going to write will be
available in the notes and I will walk
us through it and then I'll go over it
again translating it into the concepts
that we've covered okay are you ready
let's do this
so twilio functions have another great
feature
you can get access to a rest client to
the twilio rest client that
authenticated a twilio rest client from
the context object so context get twilio
client now remember that is uh going to
be using my auth token and my account
Sid and it's on this context it just
automatically is authenticated which is
really powerful because now I can get
access to my thing because this function
is running as me right so that's why it
has access to that information so
remember we want to get a hold of all of
the messages that were sent in so we're
going to use the API to do that
um and remember we could have multiple
phone numbers so I'm gonna get the
messages that were just sent to this
phone number so I'm going to await
because remember it returns a promise so
client.messages dot list
and I need to do the ones that are
specifically to my twilio number so
that's five six one
eight one six
five four three three and I'm pretty
sure that's right I'm gonna look one
more time at my uh oh there it is uh
yeah that's it so that's my my phone
number there
516-85433 you could go there it's also
on your console remember down here at
the bottom five six one eight one six
five four three three that's what I
wanted I put that there
um and in fact you know that's something
uh you could have multiple numbers and
that might be something that you want to
uh store possibly in an environment
variable so I think we should probably
do that let's let's do that so I'm going
to take uh this this number here and I'm
going to store that here you can see in
the functions and the services here we
have this environment variables let's
add to that and you'll see here actually
add my twilio credentials my account
said my off token to M so that's why
context get twilio client works is
because we've checked this if not it
won't work so but it's checked by
default so we're going to do twilio
number and that value is going to be
that and now in my code what's red is I
can use that like so I can say context
DOT twilio number I can access anything
that is in those environment variables
that way and it's now it's in this code
and now when I share this code uh you
won't need to do that you will need to
set your environment variable though
um awesome
so
um and uh now what we've got access to
well actually first we set a weight and
we need to make sure that this function
is marked a sync so that that's required
right in order to make this work so now
it's going to get the messages it's
going to return the messages and now
we're going to Loop through those
messages
um one of my favorite ways of doing that
is this four of loop so we're going to
say four message of messages
uh and for each one of those messages
we're going to go through some things so
um one thing you might not have thought
about before is that when you send a
message you can put multiple photos I
think typically Whenever I send when I
just send one or then I send another
message and another message you can
actually add multiple pictures before
you send it so um let me let's do that
let's get a hold of all of the pictures
that are available
um so we'll say comp picks I will call
we'll call our variable called picks
right uh for picture short for picture
and we'll say a weight
message now the message object that came
back from this this API now we know that
this was an API call but it is an object
and that object actually has access to
these sub resources which was media
which we we walked through this before
remember where there's the media URL and
we grabbed that media URL we looked at
all of them that were available this is
basically doing that same thing and
we're going to get all of the media that
is available
all right so
we have that we have the message we have
all of the pictures of that message and
so for each of those pictures right so
each of the pictures
I think we need to actually need to
declare the variable just to be better
there so we'll say for const pick of
picks right so we're going to make a new
variable called pick looping through
each one of these that came back from
from this array right so so
um for all of the messages for all of
the pictures in the messages now what
we're going to do is we're going to add
that to this Gallery so this is an empty
array but we're going to dynamically add
to it and the way that you add to an
array of course is with uh Gallery dot
push we're going to push a value onto
the end of that array
and we know what this is supposed to
look like right it looks like this it
looks like we have the source right so
Source here SRC is short for Source
um just from Forever in the internet uh
so image source SRC and uh I know
um from from my my notes uh and I'm
gonna pop over here real quick
um that that uh this this has uh the
media resource has this thing called a
URI on it and it's relative to this
https uh twilio.com
so let's paste that
so it's relative to that which means
that if I'm going to display it I need
to let our people know if I'm going to
give it a full URL which it it requires
right it requires this full URL so it's
got the front part of it and then I'm
going to use the pick as a property
called URI which we saw and remember
what happens
um
is it has this content type if we want
to without an extension uh the media is
returned now I know that by default this
is going to give me this pic.uri is
going to end in dot Json so I want to
replace that I'm going to use the string
method to replace the dot Json right I
don't I don't want that.json I want it
to be no extension at all um so I'm
going to use this empty string so I'm
going to replace the end of what this
pick was with DOT Json I'm going to
replace that with an empty string which
will remove it essentially right that's
what we're going to do now I'm going to
do a comma because I want to do more I
want to have the description I want to
put the description here is required
because that's what the little text is
at the bottom that it says and that's
whatever they texted in in their message
right so I'm in this Loop I'm looping
through each one of the picks but I'm
also I have access to this message
because I'm in this inner loop here
right so I still have access to the
outer loop which is message dot body
right so those are inflated
um so that's whatever the text was that
somebody sent it in and I we should also
we'll make that the alt text too so alt
tags are handy for um
accessibility reasons there there are
people you might not think about this
but there are people who
um are going to use your application
that are using it without
um being able to see some people are
vision impaired and they have screen
readers and uh alt tags are awesome for
that you always want to make sure that
you make things accessible for people
who can't see uh what it is that you're
providing and ALT tags are an excellent
way of doing that this is just one way
that you can make uh your application
more accessible and everybody wins by it
and then finally I'm just going to grab
this last thumbnail width here 200
pixels uh we can see later if people
want something different than that uh
what to do so so our Gallery array for
each one of those pictures it's going to
add to it right so so it's going to go
and it's going to add each one of those
and we're still going to return that
gallery and I think y'all I think we got
it
let's let's walk it one more time
okay so we're gonna come in here and we
are going to use the context that was
passed in uh to this function when it
was called so when somebody hits this
URL this function is going to run and
it's going to know it's going to have
access to those environment variables
that we saw it's going to get access to
an authenticated client and that client
is logged in with my account Sid and my
auth token and we're going to create an
empty array this Gallery thing here
we're going to create an empty array
it's a list that we're going to populate
we're going to take our messages and
we're going to push them into this array
so that uh it has the format that is
expected which is right here we're going
to turn what our messages look like into
this so that later we can use them that
way so the way that we do that is we use
this client this client is a ref client
and it's going to hit the messages
endpoint and we know that it's going to
do a get but it's been abstracted for us
so just so we're just say hey list all
of the numbers that were sent to this
twilio number and those are this this
context here again this is passed in in
the two really a number is set in my
environment variables over here so we're
set because because you could have
multiple right you could have multiple
twilio phone numbers so we want to say
only the ones that were sent to so we're
very we're being very specific we're
querying messages that were sent to this
number not from this number but to this
number and we're going to Loop through
each one of those messages and for each
one of those messages the object that's
returned from this has this property
called media which lets us get to a sub
resource and you'll remember in the Json
there was a there's a link to this and
we could go and query this ourselves but
we don't need to because the API has
wrapped that for us it's very nice it's
a nice abstraction and we're we're going
to get the list of those picks and again
this is asynchronous we're using this
we're waiting for it to come back we're
waiting for these values to come back so
once we have these picks we're going to
Loop through each of the pick and we are
going to push out
um a source that has this we know that
they all need to start with API
twilio.com because the URI itself this
URI here his relative meaning it doesn't
contain the forward slash of this so
um we're going to say this is where it
lives this is the API call that we want
you to do
um to get this content is API
actually.com whatever is in the pick URI
because that's unique to each one of the
pictures and that URI comes with a Json
at the end of it so if you look here
um
let's see if we if we look here we can
see that it ends in this dot Json right
and we want to get rid of that because
when you do get rid of it what happens
is it Returns the actual picture we did
that I don't know if you remember that
earlier we did that so um
so that will be removed and then we're
going to use the message and the message
is coming from here right so the message
for each of these messages we're going
to get the message.body and the
description and the alt tag for it the
alternate text we're going to set and
that's from that this is the required
for remember this looks exactly like
what happened here so we are returning
that uh here and it should return Json
I'm going to save it we are going to
deploy it we are going to cross our
fingers because this we are at that
point where we hope that the code that
we wrote works and if it didn't it is
okay if it didn't work we are going to
work through it we might get an error we
might not understand exactly what that
error is and we're going to work through
it but I am going to save this and
deploy it now I let's assume that I gave
this out I gave this out so now if
somebody hits this API here we go so
that's what it was before if we hit it
we should see
burritos we got it so it says look at
this beautiful burrito I texted that hit
wow look at the the clarity of the
burrito oh my gosh you can see the rice
in the burrito Emoji that's impressive I
didn't know that look at that cat all
right so um
in fact let's go let's go hit it uh with
our
um
let's hit that same that same request I
wrote before it should be a little bit
different now uh it's coming across here
and I want to look at the response and
the response I'm going to go and I'm
gonna grab
this URL and make sure that it works so
the source right the source that came
back here is should be the picture of it
and if we look at it I should see my
beautiful burrito oh look at this thing
I believe that burritos uh when they can
stand up by themselves uh that's a sign
of a good burrito look at that burrito I
got that in Arizona oh man
and what we did with this code is
actually pretty common now in an app
like the one that we're building
probably eventually what you're going to
do is you're going to store those photos
that were submitted into a database
right and you're going to do that from
this incoming message function you're
going to get it you're going to store it
if it's valid if it's a valid picture
you don't want to show pictures that
aren't you're going to store it in a
database and then you're going to format
it for whatever your client is you're
going to get that from a database so
maybe instead of coming back from this
API you're going to come from a database
API and you're going to pull back your
information and then you're going to
push it through and that database is
going to be in its own format but you're
going to make it match whatever it is
that you are trying to push out there
you're not gonna it's not gonna look
exactly like the message right I'm not
going to send back one of these messages
and make my API look like that I'm going
to shape the data that's what that's
called I'm going to shape my data in the
way that I want it to be used and we
came with the spec this is the shape of
the data so we took the data and we
shaped it we formed it into what was
expected
all these burritos are making me hungry
I think I'm gonna go fetch one from my
favorite Taqueria I'll make sure to snap
a pic you should get one too actually
you deserve it you deserve a burrito and
when we get back we'll look at how to
fetch this data that we just generated
in our client app
so we've coded our external public API
and it's ready to be consumed now our
API uses an external API twilio and
we're going to need to use our web
framework views API to retrieve the data
and to do that we're going to need to
use the web API fetch
see apis are everywhere no wonder you
came looking for this course all right
let's make use of our server-based API
and our client-side application
all right so just like I just consumed
my burrito we are going to consume that
API that we just created so if I scroll
down here remember we're passing in this
Gallery here and we scroll down here
into this load images and this load
images gets kicked off from the API of
uh view right so Vue has these life
cycle apis and when the the things
mounted it's going to call this load
images we're going to come in to load
images and now we have some to-do's that
we have already two done so we are going
to use the messaging API to use
submitted photos we did that we did that
in our API
and then we are going to create a
web-based API that matches this expected
response we also did that didn't we we
did that so let's get rid of that all
right so here we go so this has got a
suggestion here of what to start uh
doing here so I'm going to uncomment
this so uh we're going to create a new
uh response object and we are going to
await and we are going to use Fetch and
fetch here is part of the web API that
browsers must Implement
um to do exactly what we're trying to do
right we want to fetch data from our API
now this happens to be on the same
server so we can use a relative link
like this slash API here we don't need
to specify the server right it's assumed
so uh our API we we called that right we
called it API slash pix so slash pix is
what we are going to hit there um and
you notice that it's using await because
this is an async function so fetch
returns a promise and it's going to
return that response
and uh that response has a method on it
called Json
um that will actually return the Json
representation of whatever came back so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
rid of this Gallery this hard-coded
gallery that is gone and I am going to
say await we are going to await because
this method is also asynchronous
response dot Json so that's going to get
back uh whatever is in this response
that came back this response has all
sorts of metadata about it but we just
want to get the data out of it and
that's by using this dot Json and
because our API is Json enabled it's
just going to come out
all right let's deploy it
I cannot stop oops this is not unable to
deploy because I didn't save it so I
need to save it first
I cannot stop thinking about that
burrito it was so good I submitted a
selfie of myself and I texted it to my
twilio number and I got a reply back
from my twilio trial account right and
it says uh thanks for submitting it so
if all goes well when we look here I'll
be able to show you the burrito that I
texted to my number
um so uh it's been deployed and I'm
going to come in here under this assets
and I'm going to copy this URL
and I am going to paste it here and this
View application is going to go and it's
going to hit my API and it's going to
bring back some photos into this gallery
and here it is look at the size of this
thing it was truly bigger than my head
so we click that uh we could go now we
can see my other uh beautiful burrito uh
there as well
now let's look again back here at the
client side of things and just take a
look at how beautiful this is it's just
two lines and it's hitting our apis and
that's the power
of this API we were able to hit an API
and get User submitted text messages
text photos right and it only took two
lines and really it only took one line
actually you know like if we could have
like changed some stuff on top of this
awesome now one thing that I do want to
note is that there's no authentication
at all to this API right I could I
didn't Supply any authentication
information at all it's open to everyone
and that's kind of a good thing if you
are working on a client-side application
you don't want to pass your keys around
like I would not want to put my my
twilio keys here on this page because I
don't know if you know this but you can
actually see everything that comes down
so I'm going to view the source of this
and you can see here's the source that
we're looking at and if I hadn't used
any sort of API keys I would see them
right here you don't want to leak your
keys that way check the notes for more
information on how to get around this
but typically this is what you do is you
write a server that then the server
keeps track of all the keys and you
connect to the server but if you do need
to provide some authentication locally
on the client there are ways to do that
check the notes
but look at this look at this you did
this you have designed a new interface a
text messaging interface right a a TMI
well I hope this wasn't TMI or also
known as too much information for you
you learned a whole lot about apis and
not just the web-based ones you saw them
in practice and you even built your own
one you really deserved that burrito
awesome job you've just built and
consumed your own API now here's my
question to you do you think that the
API code that we wrote together should
be considered restful
well why don't we take a look at our
weathered scavenger hunt card so it's
definitely a client server architecture
our client happens to be in this case A
View application running in the browser
and our server is a serverless node
application but any client could connect
and use this
statelessness it's definitely stateless
right we aren't requiring any prior
knowledge about the client
cash ability
hmm
well at the moment we aren't providing
any caching information though we could
right we could fairly easily pay
attention to those headers coming in and
we could respond appropriately it would
require us writing some additional code
and thinking through some of the edge
cases but we could do it let's put that
in the maybe column
layered system
yeah for sure right in fact it's a
little layered already our API is
calling another API but our client
doesn't need to know that we can also
add additional functionality and the
contract wouldn't change
code on demand we haven't even talked
about this one yet and it's the only
optional requirement basically this
means that your API returns code that is
runnable like maybe it returns an
embeddable widget or some actual
JavaScript code this doesn't make any
sense in our use case and that's totally
okay so we're going to drop this one
into the no column so we're looking good
so far but here comes the doozy uniform
interface so remember this one has four
subsections resource identification and
requests row currently we're just
representing all the messages as objects
and absolutely no way to identify them
so
we failed this sub requirement and
therefore this is a no but let's keep
going through the rest of these
pun intended sorry resource manipulation
through representations we definitely do
not allow any sort of manipulation of
the images so this is another fail
self-descriptive messages we haven't
gone over this yet but by using headers
we can tell that this is Json the
message sent down has a type and it's
clear that it should be Json decoded to
be used
hyper media as the engine of application
State and last but certainly not least
Hattie Os or hate OS
it's an often forgot about part of the
restful constraint and the idea here is
that there are links to show off what
more you could do with this and where
you could find related resources it
provides Uris or links and we did see
this in both the Spotify and twilio ones
however harness doesn't provide links to
other resources
so we don't have a restful API and
that's okay it's going to suit our needs
it does look like we can get there
pretty quickly if we wanted to one thing
I want you to gain from that exercise
though is that you now have the ability
to identify whether or not an API is
restful and I hope that felt pretty good
we've now completed the scavenger hunt
we revealed all the constraints and I
hope most of those are pretty clear
please don't feel like you need to
memorize those you can find those same
constraints littered all over the
internet
now as a prize for finishing the
constraint scavenger hunt I've dropped
links to my favorite rest API constraint
documentation for you to lean on should
you need to I've also included links to
the popular rest API Frameworks that
will help you design restful apis make
sure to check out the notes
you did it you just completed a
whirlwind introduction to apis and I
hope that you can see how much more
power they can add to your programming
Journey by looking at interfaces in
general I hope you're more comfortable
with the idea of not fully understanding
exactly how something is working but
still leaning on that abstraction to
build your tools and applications do
this all the time with physical object
interfaces and apis or application
programming interfaces they aren't all
that different I hope you enjoyed taking
this course I know I had a lot of fun
making it if you think someone you know
might benefit from this course please
share it with them I'd love to hear your
feelings your thoughts your dreams so I
threw together a little something using
a smattering of apis to capture your
feedback if you've got the time I'd love
to have you answer a quick text-based
survey text feedback to the number on
your screen well actually you know what
if you want you can also call and just
leave me a message too I use an API for
that too so please please please keep me
posted on your journey and really I
can't wait to see what you build thanks
again for hanging out and we'll see you
real soon
[Music]
foreign